[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
sur public sénat dans moins d'une heure
à 17 heures vous allez pouvoir suivre en
direct et en intégralité les questions
d'actualité au gouvernement
l'exécutif qui passe donc aujourd'hui sa
journée au parlement après la
déclaration de jean castex ce matin au
sénat les questions d'actualité tout à
l'heure un cet après midi à l'assemblée
place donc aux questions d'actualité du
sénat en bref on va vous faire vivre
tout cela avec alexandre poussard salle
des conférences alors alexandre quel est
le menu est bien tard
au menu ce soir on parlera d'écologie
puisque le premier ministre a défendu
devant le parlement son plan de relance
vert avec plus de 20 milliards d'euros
d'investissements pour l'écologie et un
plan vélo ambitieux et d'ailleurs ce
matin le premier ministre a interpellé
les sénateurs en leur disant je cite ne
riez pas messieurs les sénateurs le vélo
c'est très sérieux
et dans dix ans on pourra rallier prades
à perpignan en vélo pour aller à
travailler ensuite la droite du sénat
posera une question sur les violences
contre les pompiers les policiers et les
gendarmes le gouvernement est il assez
ferme pour faire respecter l'autorité de
l'état
les sénateurs pose la question et puis
enfin on parlera à des territoires
puisque le discours de jean castex au
sénat c'était un peu une déclaration
d'amour aux territoires et aux
collectivités locales avec un nouvel
acte de décentralisation et une relance
économique qui s'appuie sur ces
collectivités locales à la merci
beaucoup alexandre pour toutes ces
explications et on vous retrouve tout au
long de cette émission avec de nombreux
invités à votre micro
[Musique]
alexandre en a parlé à l'instant jean
castex se présente depuis qu'il a été
nommé premier ministre comme un élu
local l'homme de prades l'homme des
territoires
il leur a encore accordé une large place
ce matin lors de son discours devant le
sénat
résumé avec jonathan dutriez que le
premier ministre vous avez la parole
jean castex a envoyé aux sénateurs un
signal attendu face à eux pendant deux
heures et demie il s'est posé en premier
ministre des territoires territoire le
mot a d'ailleurs été prononcée 30 fois
par l'ancien maire de prades
ils seront donc logiquement la pierre
angulaire de sa politique l'état je les
dis est le garant des fonctions
régaliennes qui c'est l'unité de la
nation
mais pour l'ensemble des grandes
transition écologique économique et
sociale les acteurs territoriaux doivent
d'être à la manoeuvre devant la chambre
d'hôte jean castex a aussi tenu à
s'adresser particulièrement aux élus
locaux et a salué leur engagement
pendant la crise
les élus ont été remarquables
d'implication et de dévouement a
commencé à commencer par les maires qui
ont comme toujours vtt combattants de la
première ligne et de la première heure
lors de son discours jean castex a
surtout longuement détaillé sa vision en
matière de décentralisation vision
largement convergente avec celle du
sénat le locataire de matignon souhaite
accélérer la marche via le projet de loi
dit 3d et délégué aux collectivités
davantage de compétences notamment en
matière de santé
je souhaite à cet effet que les régions
les départements et les
intercommunalités puis se prendre une
part plus grande dans la gestion de
notre système de santé qu'elle puisse si
elles le souhaitent s'associer aux
investissements que nous allons y
décider
jean castex a aussi confirmé la tenue
prochaine d'une conférence nationale des
territoires ainsi que la présentation en
conseil des ministres avant la fin du
mois d'un projet de loi organique
ouvrant le dos
la différenciation permettant aux
collectivités davantage
d'expérimentation au niveau local et on
va revenir sur ce discours de jean
castex castex ce matin avec quatre
invités sur ce plateau
enfin quatre invités tout court puisque
trois invités sur ce plateau jérôme
bascher bonjour bonjour vous êtes
sénateur les républicains de l'oise
merci d'être avec nous également avec
nos frédéric marchand bon je vais vous
faire la république en marche du nord
jean yves le conte bonjour vous êtes
sénateur socialiste représentant les
français établis hors de france 3 a
invité sur ce plateau est une invitée à
distance un julia à mouzon bonjour was
held fondatrice du site internet mon
mandat local
merci à tous les cadres d'être sur ce
plateau pour parler bien de jean castex
jean castex l'homme des territoires
jérôme bascher ce sont des mots qui vous
ont touché cette ode au territoire
ce matin au sénat hier à l'assemblée de
jean castex
alors là oui j'ai été touché touchés par
cet acte de repentance qui consistait à
dire que pendant trois ans les avait
oubliés et que donc et que donc
effectivement on pouvait penser aux
territoires l'intelligence des
territoires et je n'ai entendu dans la
bouche du président de la république il
ya un mois cette chose-là exister c'est
bien qu'on le découvre trois ans après
il avait cru bon un moment le président
de la république de faire un tour de
france des mers un grand show un
roadshow 1 comme il faut le dire qu'on
appelait le grand débat qui n'a servi à
rien vu que un an après on s'était
aperçu que rien n'avait été changé
on a un vrai du local havrais élu local
dire de communes rurales
depuis les orientales ils connaissent à
mme le maire de prades et conseiller
départemental également il faut le dire
il était d'ailleurs le président du
groupe plr au conseil départemental
il a abandonné la fonction pour
janssoone notre collègue sénateur il
connaît bien ses territoires et c'est
cette capacité on va voir maintenant ce
qu'il en fait et oui il reste de
nombreux points d'interrogation frédéric
marchand on a entendu et bien la
déclaration d'amour au territoire mais
on attend les détails on attend la
répartition des compétences on attend
d'avoir les détails de la loi 3d qu'on
en finit pas de nous annoncer
oui il va plutôt que de repentance mais
bon effectivement certains cultivent le
sens de la formule moi je dirais
effectivement que le premier ministre
est venu confirmer ce qui se passe
depuis 2010 est moi je viens d'un
département où la logique de territoire
est très importante et où effectivement
l'état a parfaitement intégré notamment
dans cet arrondissement de la sambre
avesnois ce qui était un territoire et
les problématiques particulières du
territoire pour le reste effectivement
la feuille de route du premier ministre
il l'a dit hier à l'assemblée l'a redit
aujourd'hui au sénat c'est un
gouvernement de combat avec des
propositions très concrètes qui ont été
faites à la fois hier et aujourd'hui et
donc et bien la suite va s'écrire genre
yves leconte à ce que vous jugez vous
aussi que les territoires avaient été
oubliés dans la première partie du
quinquennat et puis gérant de bachar en
parlait à l'instant ce n'est pas la
première fois qu'on parle de
décentralisation c'était déjà la leçon
qu'ils avaient été tirés par emmanuel
macron à l'issue du grand débat et pour
l'instant il n'y a pas eu de concret bah
tout à fait parce qu'en fait la
répétition ne constitue pas une ligne
politique
ça constitue justin il l'a déjà fait il
ya un an il leur fait ce choix à chaque
fois c'est difficile pour moi de parler
territoire en étant élu des français à
l'étranger mais ce que je peux dire
c'est qu'il est important c'est le
mandat de construire de cours sur une
politique sur le sur la base des codes
de la connaissance du terrain et c'est
ce qui a singulièrement manqué depuis
2010 est et on l'a vu à de nombreuses
reprises et on remplace sa part des
répétitions de repentance à chaque fois
et là c'est pareil
une fois de plus on a vu combien l'état
centralisé ne pouvait pas fonctionner ne
faisait pas face à la crise sanitaire on
remplaça maintenant par la mantra
territoire alors qu'il faut s'interroger
sur l'ensemble du fonctionnement des
institutions sur la capacité
effectivement de faire remonter les
problèmes de terrain pour pouvoir avoir
des politiques qui réponde à ça mais
aussi sur finalement tout une
architecture de l'exécutif qui tourne
autour d'une seule personne
ce qui a aussi démontré ses défaillances
au cours de cette crise sanitaire il
faut s'interroger aussi là dessus
oui peut-être un problème aussi
démocratique jeudi à mouzon bon on a
entendu pas encore énormément de détails
un dans le discours du premier ministre
mais quelques points
le droit la différenciation qui va être
reconnu par une loi organique ou encore
aidé à la création d'emplois dans les
services déconcentrés de l'état au
niveau des départements
bon tout ça ce sont des annonces mais ce
que ça va réellement permettre selon
vous de résoudre et bien notre problème
démocratique faire remonter les
problèmes du terrain comme le disais à
l'instant j'arrive le comptant alors
leproux qui est marquant pour moi dans
ce discours de politique générale c'est
le fait qu'on va dans la bonne direction
la décentralisation aujourd'hui c'est la
solution à de nombreux problèmes aux
minots ouvre aux problématiques des
territoires et danse dans ce discours du
coup la direction et la peur ça c'est
clair
nous chez mon mandat local informe mille
élus parents et on a une communauté
d'élus de 3000 et pendant tout le dect
ou le confinement et tout le
déconfinement on les a accompagnés sur
ces sujets et les élus aujourd'hui son
seul face à toutes ces problématiques
donc la vraie question aujourd'hui c'est
est ce que ce gouvernement qui insiste
sur sa capacité d'exécution va être en
mesure d'accorder les paroles et les
actes
et il ya des attentes qui sont très
fortes il ya des décalages qui sont très
forts dans les territoires entre ce qui
devrait se passer savoir des réponses
très réactif de l'administration aux
élus aux maires qui les sollicitent une
grande réactivité une grande
transparence dans la règle
on en est très loin qu'on est sur des
retards qui sont très importants qui
peuvent être très importants mais une
fois que nous a dit la préfecture avait
mis un nom elle répond et on a donc un
vrai sujet comme l'a souligné le premier
ministre
des exécutions donc sur ce sujet de
déléguer davantage aux territoires
frédéric marchand oui un problème
d'exécution un autre problème épineux
qui demeure et bien c'est celui réclamé
à cor et à cri par les collectivités de
l'autonomie fiscale alors que l'état
fait précisément le contraire notamment
avec la taxe d'habitation qui a été
vraiment la graine de discorde depuis le
début du quinquennat
oui mais partant du principe que c'est
un tout on s'adresse effectivement aux
élus locaux on s'adresse aussi à la
population et pardon dire effectivement
que quand on s'adresse à la population
et qu'on lui explique que la pression
fiscale va baisser c'est un discours qui
est plus content dable sachant
qu'aujourd'hui on est en capacité là
aussi de faire la démonstration que la
compensation sera au rendez vous oui
vous êtes d'accord avec cela jérôme batx
et à la compensation sera au rendez vous
vous dit votre collègue alors en tout
cas pour répondre juste la question
précédente qui est extrêmement
importante qui est l'autonomie
financière et fiscale
cet après midi même dans l'hémicycle
bruno le maire vient nous annoncer que
les régions devront baisser leurs impôts
de production et que l'état les
compensera et donc on voit bien qu'on
continue le même chemin par rapport à la
taxe d'habitation qui était on enlève de
l'autonomie financière collectivités
locales on continue à le faire cette
fois-ci avec les régions en dix ans on
compense jusqu'à présent il n'y a pas eu
de manière historique depuis 1981 de
compensation qui était maintenue dans le
temps donc on sait très bien qu'une
compensation de l'état ça s'étiole au
fur et à mesure que l'on creuse des
déficits
et comme on les a beaucoup creuser cette
année il ya aucune chance qu'elle soit
maintenue jean yves le conte vous
partager ses inquiétudes sur la question
de la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation
alors que on apprend on a aussi eu des
éléments comme quoi eh bien cette
suppression elle était bien maintenu
totalement même si elle ça serait un
petit peu reporter dans le temps pour la
dernière tranche des plus aisés ce
partage
ces interrogations je partage les
constats qui viennent d'être évoqués
mais attire aussi l'attention sur le
fait que c'est assez étonnant que le
même jour on parle d'autonomie fiscale
des collectivités et qu'on déplore un
jugement de la cour de justice de
l'union européenne sur ce que la
politique fiscale de l'irlande
si on veut dans un marché unique
être capable d'avoir une politique et
des recettes fiscales correct on ne peut
pas simplement on doit discuter de cette
de la fiscalité au niveau de l'ensemble
du marché
alors bien entendu après on peut
décliner femme encore bien d'accord mais
moi je trouve assez étonnant que le jour
où on va des ponts déplore on va
déplorer de ping fiscale de l'irlande et
en même temps on va parler d'auto non
veut parler d'autonomie fiscale
il faut de ce point de vue là c'est les
poissons rouges par le poisson rouge ça
ça va plus il faut essayer d'avoir une
vision globale et c'est tout ce qui
manque à ce premier ministre il a parlé
des territoires mais tout ce qu'on vit
depuis trois mois c'est une perturbation
des fondamentale sur les biens communs
mondiaux sur le climat sur la santé et
on a pas on a aussi besoin d'une vision
globale
on a aussi besoin de nous dire des
choses qui nous a pas dit il nous a
quasiment pas parlé d'europe
il nous a pas parlé du tout de la
manière dont la même place la france que
ce soit la france jacobine où la france
des territoires se projeter dans la
mondialisation
et pourtant ce que nous avons vécu
depuis trois depuis trois mois nécessite
une réponse globale avec une force qui
se projette à l'international avec
marcheurs oui sur la question européenne
et sur la façon dont l'europe doit
affronter cette crise je pense que la
meilleure réponse elle a été apportée
par le couple franco-allemand et par la
volonté ferme du président de la
république qui a réussi à gagner en gal
a marqué à sa cause pour faire en sorte
qu effectivement pour la première fois
l'europe décide de parler financièrement
et nous espérons le si tout va bien
et puis c'est ouvrir des pistes qui vont
être utiles pour les étals d'union mais
bien évidemment pour la france au
premier chef
en tout cas s'il ya un sujet où les
collectivités ont fait leurs preuves en
tout cas selon le premier ministre et il
n'est pas le seul c'est celui de la
crise sanitaire la crise de l'aco vide
c'est d'ailleurs par ce sujet que jean
castex a débuté son discours il a
annoncé lé masque obligatoire dans les
lieux publics fermés
la semaine prochaine on l'écoutait le
port du masque constitue avec le respect
des gestes dits barrière une mesure de
prévention et de protection efficace
j'ai donc proposé que l'obligation de le
porter soit renforcée dans tous les
établissements recevant du public
clo en particulier ce qui n'est pas le
cas aujourd'hui les commerces
cela nécessite un décret alors que dans
les locaux dits professionnels
cela suppose une évolution des
protocoles sanitaires régissant les
activités concernées nous envisagions
une entrée en vigueur de ces
dispositions le 1er août
parce qu'encore une fois nous agissons
dans une logique préventive et pas sous
l'empiré de l'urgence on va parler de
cette obligation de masques mais d'abord
julien à mouzon pour vous quel rôle les
collectivités ont-elles joué dans cette
crise et doivent-elles continuer à jouer
selon vous quels enseignements peut-on
en tirer un enseignement principal c'est
l'enseignement de la proximité
et comme l'a souligné le premier
ministre les collectivités elles sont en
premières prises pour gérer la vie des
gens les collectivités gèrent la vie des
gens donc c'est vraiment ce sujet là qui
est au coeur du fonctionnement
territoriale et c'est ce sujet qui est
important finalement les interdictions
de porc de les interdictions plutôt les
obligations de port de masques des
interdictions de circulation dense être
est ce parce public
les fermetures
la scion tout ça ça a été géré par la
collectivité locale et et on se sent si
elles sont vraiment essentiel donc pour
répondre à cette question à ces
questions de kristen bell qui on le voit
nous ramène à des enjeux très locaux et
très quotidien maintenant je ne suis pas
tout à fait d'accord avec avec le cp
avec notre notre collègue sénateur qui a
annoncé que jean plutôt qu'à qui a
stipulé que jean castex que ça réduit
alors un plus de dix ans avec plus de
hauteur à plus de 10 pour générale je
pense que les élus comme les citoyens
ont une lassitude des discours généraux
ont une lassitude des paroles général et
ont envie de choses concrètes
les élus qui sont encore clairement pour
gérer ces questions concrètes et cette
délégation aux élus
c'est exactement ce qu'il faut faire
dans ce dispositif maintenant les effets
d'annoncé ont leurs limites
on l'a vu sur la conférence nationale
des territoires mais déjà des
conférences nationales et territoires
qui ont été lancées elles n'ont pas été
suivies d'effets les conférences
nationales de territoire avec les
associations d'élus se sont arrêtées
elles n'ont pas été suivi dans la durée
c'est le cas aussi sur la loi engageant
les proximités on attend toujours
certains décrets sur la loire qui n'ont
de la même façon pas été promulguée le
l'état de façon générale le gouvernement
un problème de suivi et un problème
d'exécution sur ces questions de
politique de lui
frédéric marchand un problème de suivi
c'est l'exécution qui ne suit pas c'est
un peu d'ailleurs ce que disait jean
castex lors de son discours il ya un
problème d'exécution la conférence
nationale des territoires effectivement
à les relancer
cet été mais qu'est ce qui nous garantit
qu'elle va aboutir à quelque chose on a
bien vu que ça avait été très compliquée
depuis le début du quinquennat sur ce
géant veut dire que là où il ya une
volonté il ya un chemin le premier
ministre a tracé le chemin ce matin
reprenant donc effectivement les
attendus qui avait été développé
là aussi par le précédent premier
ministre je pense qu'il est un peu
facile de noyer le bébé avec l'eau du
bain
s'agissant des collectivités
territoriales et la conférence nationale
qui s'était tenu il ya quand même eu des
décisions financières qui ont été prises
notamment en matière de maintien des
dotations financières je pense qu'on ne
peut pas passer par pertes et profits
donc je crois que j'ai c'est vrai dire
sous les 6 mois elle demandé
effectivement se réunir tous les six
mois mais aussi du centre l'exécutif
elle passe aussi à des situations pour
le moins extraordinaire et convenons que
ce premier semestre est quand même un
premier semestre un peu particulier avec
la fin de l'année dernière a été aussi
assez la crise avec les grèves notamment
jérôme jérôme bascher vous jugez vous
vous aussi que ben on a pour le coup il
ya un problème d'exécution qui s'est
manifesté mais on voit qu'il ya quand
même bien un premier ministre qui veut
justement résoudre ce problème exécution
sa volonté est claire et je pense que
l'expérience qu'il a eue
voilà deux pour le déconfinement lui est
extrêmement utile et qu'il a pu
percevoir les difficultés de ce pays et
notamment il l'a très bien souligné dans
son discours de politique générale 1 le
constat est juste c'est le l'état ne
sait pas faire la logistique et donc on
a laissé faire l'état central on a
laissé faire les agences régionales de
santé à gérer des problèmes de
logistique alors qu'ils en étaient
strictement incapable alors même que les
collectivités locales les mairies les
départements les régions la nôtre avec
xavier bertrand ont su distribuer des
masques ont été commandés
alors même que l'état lui aurait terres
arables de communication je trouve que
chaque jour de chaque citoyen on a en a
et vous le savez aussi comme dans
l'exemple mais je prends l'exemple des
autres ans je peux donc en témoigner et
il va participer dans le monde
département de l'oise
on a fait aussi un certain nombre de
choses pour les ehpad pour les visiteurs
que je dénonçais mois le 4 mars et dans
lequel le ministre de l'époque m'avait
ri au nez en disant que je disait
n'importe quoi il a dû reconnaître
qu'ils s'étaient trompés
il a dû reconnaître parce que dans
l'oise on a été touchés les premiers que
l'état montre est d ores et déjà ces
défaillances qu'on ne savait pas fermer
une école
savez-vous cela on ne savait pas fermer
une école je ne savais pas qu'il faisait
l'état était totalement désorganisée
voilà la vraie leçon et je pense que
j'en serai ce texte en tirera les leçons
un jean yves le conte justement jean
castex va donner plus de compétences
sanitaires aux élus est ce que pour vous
à travers cette crise ça montre que
c'est nécessaire j'ai le sentiment mais
aussi pour avoir vu
des français qui vivait en chine qui
s'interrogeait comment est ce que c'est
possible qu'on ne puisse pas commandé de
masques alors que nous on est capable
d'envoyer tout simplement parce qu'on ne
demande pas des énarques de faire du
commerce international c'est un métier
différent et on a bien constaté que
pendant quelques semaines c'était ça
marchait pas et donc de ce point de vue
là il ya déjà des il ya des choses à
changer les compétences de l'ensemble
des élus et les compétences de ce qu'il
représente sur le terrain elles sont
utiles dans ces moments là quand il faut
faire quelque chose d'absolument nouveau
mais il n'y a pas qu'une question
d'exécution parce que les difficultés
elles arrivent tous les jours dans ces
périodes là mais si vous n'avez pas de
cap
mais finalement l'exécution ça sert pas
à grand chose
or moi j'ai l'impression que finalement
le seul cap d'emmanuel macron c'est la
réforme des retraites
pour le reste c'est 2 d'exécution mais
pour aller où on ne sait pas on va
rester encore un petit point sur la
question de la crise sanitaire parce que
l'une des annonces quand même de ce
discours on l'a entendu tout à l'heure
de la part du premier ministre c'est de
rendre les masques obligatoire dès la
semaine prochaine et alexandre vous êtes
d'ailleurs avec bernard jomier sénateur
écologiste rattaché au groupe socialiste
de paris
ben ainslie qui est ailleurs et médecins
effectivement bernard jomier sénateurs
et médecin de profession et jean castex
le premier ministre qui a accéléré le
calendrier du port du masque obligatoire
dans les lieux publics clos
emmanuel macron avait parlé du 1er août
finalement ce sera la semaine prochaine
c'est une bonne décision bernard joly ça
devrait appliquer ça devrait déjà être
appliquée serre que le port du masque
dans les milieux clos qu'on va faire ses
courses dans un magasin
c'est une mesure simple et on sait que
le masque ci n'est pas forcément une
mesure pour se protéger du virus les
mesures qui protègent les autres de
façon très efficace
donc si tout le monde porte un masque
dans les milieux clos qui sont les
milieux qui pose vraiment problème
eh bien on devrait pouvoir freiner
considérablement l'épidémie le fait que
le gouvernement accélère cette mesure de
port du masque obligatoire
est ce que ce n'est pas inquiétant
concernant l'évolution de l'épidémie
peut-être qu'ils ont des informations
qui ne sont pas très positives non ce
qui est inquiétant c'est deux choses on
est en bruit de fond de l'épidémie c'est
dire en à un niveau le virus circule
il n'est pas éradiquée ça on le savait
mais ils circulent en bruit de fond il
ya deux choses qui sont inquiétantes la
première
et que il suffit pas d'édicter une
mesure pour les autres si on veut que la
population l'appli il faut se
l'appliquer à soi-même et moi je suis
désolé du spectacle deux ministres lors
de passation de pouvoir qui se sont
embrassés goulûment devant les caméras
ou même du ministre de la santé qui
aiment de multiples occasions est
apparue en milieu clos à moins d'un
mètre sans porter une masse et la
deuxième chose c'est que nous avons des
capacités teste actuellement qui sont
trop faibles à paris alors qu'il ya peu
de circulation de virus le délai moyen
pour se faire tester actuellement ces
cinq à dix jours qu'est ce qui va se
passer si l'épidémie s'accélère on voit
bien qu'on n'est pas dans une situation
qui est satisfaisante
et moi je dis attention il ya un risque
si l'épidémie repas à ce qu'on soit
débordée donc ça veut dire que pour
l'instant on n'est pas prêt à subir une
deuxième vague de l'épidémie
mais tous les acteurs de terrain qu'on a
auditionné à la commission denquête
depuis la semaine dernière et encore
hier soir des acteurs de terrain
parisiens franciliens et d'autres
régions nous ont dit on n'est pas prêt à
l'heure actuelle comment vous expliquer
ce retard du gouvernement qui aurait dû
armée quand même rapidement le pays
après notre expérience de la première
crise sanitaire
beaucoup de choses ont été faites mais
comme je voulais dix le nombre de tests
restent tout à fait insuffisant je ne
sais pas où sont les tests les circuits
sont mal organisées alors j'ai bien j'ai
bien noté que maintenant les pharmaciens
soient autorisés à délivrer des trod des
tests rapides et moi je trouve que c'est
une bonne mesure mais dans les
laboratoires d'analysés médicales
ça ne fonctionne pas d'une façon qui
soit suffisante et par ailleurs il faut
mobiliser le secteur ambulatoire
il faut pas répéter l'erreur de la
première vague qui a été d'écarter tous
les acteurs de ville de la gestion de
l'épidémie et de tout concentrer sur
l'hôpital qui se retrouvait de fait à
devoir gérer tout à la fois et ça a été
très compliqué maintenant qu'il faut
bien tirer les leçons de cette première
vague merci beaucoup bernard jomier pour
votre intervention
merci beaucoup à alexandre on entend une
réelle inquiétude de la part de berne a
rajeuni et frédéric marchand qu'est ce
que ça vous inspire le fait aussi que et
bien jean castex il a commencé son
discours sur la crise sanitaire
serty à la crise économique et la crise
sociale mais il a bien dit la crise
sanitaire elle n'est toujours pas
derrière nous - delà la crise sanitaire
est toujours là et je pense qu'il ya
effectivement une prise de conscience de
nos concitoyens qui devrait être
davantage prégnante qu'elle ne l'est
aujourd'hui à titre personnel séjour qui
ont passé j'ai eu l'occasion de me
promener c'est là dans la métropole
lilloise et je peux vous dire que les
consignes sanitaires ne sont pas
forcément respectée quand vous à
discuter quand vous échangez avec
certains certains vous disent ah mais
non mais c'est derrière nous nous avons
été confinés nous avons besoin de
liberté
non ça continue vous sentez cette
inquiétude à face à ce relâchement vous
vous le disiez gérant de bachar loi ça a
été l'un des premier cluster
on n'a pas tous deux reprises 1er 0 et
est assez bas pour l'instant dans le
département et moi je n'ai cessé de dire
y compris sur votre plateau que les le
respect des gestes barrières étaient
strictement nécessaire je pense que la
mesure annoncée par jean castex est la
bonne mesure on voit quand même
l'accélération dimanche dans sa dans le
parisien des médecins appellent au port
du masque dans les lieux publics clos
mardi le président de la république j'ai
l'impression une fois encore dit que
c'est le premier round sans avoir
vraiment consulter il improvise encore
une réponse
là on va concertée mais lui qu'on certes
pas et jean castex dans l'expérience qui
est la sienne et la demande générale
d'ailleurs générale prend une bonne
mesure qui est d'accélérer le le port du
masque
mais comme bien de le dire mon collègue
marchand faisons le d'ores et déjà
n'attendons pas des gens et le comtois
si vous êtes satisfait par cette mesure
annoncée ce matin par le premier
ministre et puis parce que pour le coup
à la pandémie au niveau mondial voit
bien qu'elle se poursuit à leers et on
n'a jamais vu d d d d augmentation de
constats mination constater tous les
jours aussi élevé qu'actuellement
donc on ne veut pas du tout dire c'est
derrière nous alors il est évident que
voilà après trois mois de confinement ou
deux mois de confinement n'a envie de
souffler un peu mais bon ben voilà une
fois qu'on il faut faire gaffe un peu
même si c'est pas sympa de porter un
masque si c'est fasse un pas il faut le
faire il faut donner l'exemple
julien mouzon est-ce que vous jugez
qu'aujourd'hui les collectivités sont
mieux préparés pour faire face à cette
deuxième vague dont on ne cesse de
parler et qui va certainement arriver
plus vite qu'on ne le pense oui alors
bien sûr mieux préparés comme tous les
citoyens mieux préparés comme tous les
commerçants à mieux préparer mieux
outillés évidemment maintenant
effectivement plus les consignes et les
décisions du gouvernement sont claires
plus elles permettent aux collectivités
elles aussi de relayer auprès de tous
leurs habitants des consignes claires
les choses claires et c'est vrai que sur
ces sur ces sujets là on a senti pendant
les trois mois de confinement beaucoup
de flottement beaucoup d'hésitations
aujourd'hui tous les tous les décideurs
publics tous les locaux attendent un car
effectivement extrêmement fort et des
mesures de précaution à des mesures
d'anticipation d'une éventuelle deuxième
vague qui pourrait revenir avec donc des
mesures de précaution et d'obligations
aux ports du bassin très musclé très
pour ce port du masque à qui sera rendue
obligatoire en milieu clos à partir de
la semaine prochaine
pour conclure sur des bombes ainsi
s'intéresser aux relations que va
entretenir jean castex avec le sénat
jean castex dont le grand-père était
sénateur qui a immédiatement rendu
visite à gérard larcher une fois nommé
premier ministre a aussi rendu hommage
au travail des sénateurs sur la question
de la décentralisation ce matin écoutez
je tiens à vous remercier monsieur le
président cher gérard larcher pour les
50 propositions du sénat pour une
nouvelle génération de la
décentralisation et je salue les deux
rapporteurs messieurs philippe bas et
jean marie bockel
toutes celles et ceux qui connaissent
ici ma conception des choses ne peuvent
pas douter que ces propositions feront
de ma part l'objet d'un examen très
attentif et très bienveillant et
attentif et bienveillant je vends ma
chère il rend hommage aux travaux de la
majorité sénatoriale
il est issu de vos rangs il adresse une
ode au territoire finalement il offre
peu d'angle d'attac pour la droite
sénatoriale c'est un peu compliqué pour
vous on cherche pas à attaquer l'homme
sasson voilà il se trouve que la droite
c'est le gaullisme social me va assez
bien et jean castex me va c'est bien je
ne connais pas ce que je fais c'est un
peu edouard philippe
mais c'est vrai on a beaucoup de talents
à droite et donc il est temps qu'on
exerce réellement le pouvoir oui non
mais ça vous offrent peu d'angle d'attac
quand même nos recherches parce que
c'est le compliqué vous savez pour la
noix la face à je crois que le discours
de bruno retailleau extrêmement claire
dans sa réponse ce matin c'est nous
avons beaucoup entendu pendant trois ans
on a soi disant beaucoup écouté les
français on a peu agi alors on a eu non
pas un discours de politique générale
mais un discours de généralités
dorénavant on veut un discours des actes
aux fins joindre les actes à la parole
c'est un discours qui était quand même
attentif et bienveillant pour reprendre
les mots de jean castex vis-à-vis des
sénateurs à ce que c'est a même bien de
d'améliorer les relations entre
l'exécutif et le sénat des relations qui
ont été très compliqués depuis ce mandat
plusieurs sénateurs l'ont rappelé à lors
de leurs interventions ce matin jean
yves le conte mais de toute façon le
sénat n'a pas d'autre moyen que de
convaincre on peut jamais être dans une
réaction de relations de force avec le
avait avec un gouvernement et si on veut
faire évoluer les choses
c'est en améliorant les textes qui nous
viennent de l'assemblée nationale et en
convainquant l'assemblée nationale qu'il
faut maintenir ce que nous proposons
donc automatiquement nous devons être
dans cette démarche constructive
quel que soit ce qu'on peut penser après
des orientations générales
donc oui de ce point de vue là ça a
l'air d'être un homme tout à fait tout
est fait urbain et par rapport à la
décentralisation nous savons combien il
a fallu d'audace au début à pierre
mauroy et à françois mitterrand pour le
faire et lui en faudra
probablement encore plus vis-à-vis des
tendances jacobine du président de la
république pour aller dans quelque chose
qui est à l'évidence son identité et sa
conviction étendant jacobine d'emmanuel
macro à ce que jean castex est là aussi
pour rééquilibrer bien cette image d'un
emmanuel macron président des villes
centralisateur jacobin frédéric marchand
vous parlez d'image moi je ne vois pas
je veux au contraire une complémentarité
un duo qui est aujourd'hui à la tête de
l'état et qui a pour mission de porter
un objectif de fixer le cap et c'est ce
que le premier ministre a fait
aujourd'hui le président de la
république l'a fait le 14 juillet moi
j'ai trouvé deux interventions qui se
complètent parfaitement et des
perspectives pour la suite qui sont je
pense tout à fait intéressante
julia mouzon jean castex jouer la carte
de l'élu local
on l'a dit et répété maire de prades une
ville de 6000 habitants là son accent du
sud ouest etc
mais edouard philippe était lui aussi un
élu local ce n'est donc pas réellement
nouveau finalement cette carte pour le
premier ministre
moi j'ai pas la même lecture
effectivement elle est maire de prades
mais c'est aussi un haut fonctionnaire
c'est pas un élu démunis c'est une base
en aluminium et c'est un élu qui est
depuis longtemps très proche des cercles
de pouvoir
c'est pas le cas des élus locaux en
général les élus locaux sont isolés et
les élus locaux sont démunis sur deux
non
le sujet donc la question c'est est ce
que ce gouvernement d'en prendre la
mesure
est-ce que le gouvernement va prendre la
mesure de l'isolément de la difficulté
pour les élus locaux aujourd'hui
administrer leur commune je vous parlais
tout à l'heure des visioconférences que
nous avons organisées dans leurs
finances
on a eu des centaines d'élus qui se sont
connectés auquel on a répondu en direct
toutes les semaines sur toutes les
mesures gouvernementales j'ai été mise
en place
on répond à des centaines d'élus qui ont
des questions sur la politique mise en
oeuvre par le gouvernement qui ne savent
pas quoi faire qui ne trouvent pas de
qualité ne comprennent pas parfois les
démarches qui sont indiqués les mesures
qui sont prises les réglementations qui
doivent passer
donc on a un véritable enjeu encore le
jeune brad est d'accompagner londres au
quotidien de suivi d'encadrement et de
caf a donné pour tous les élus locaux
pour que ce gouvernement puisse
réellement effectué ce nouvel acte de
décentralisation d'accord l'isolément
des élus locaux à cette détresse que
dont vous parle julia maison oui mais ce
n'est pas forcément là pour le coup
uniquement le gouvernement et c'est cela
aussi qui a dit ce matin jean castex à
savoir c'est la mise en application qui
pose problème lorsque le ministre de
l'éducation nationale jean michel
blanquer sort la première version du
protocole sanitaire de 53 pages ça ne va
pas ça ne va pas vous n'êtes pas mère
dans un village avec une classe dans
lesquels vous vous mettez en trois jours
en trois jours en application 53 pages
de protocole sanitaire
il ya donc là il s'était fait déborder
jean michel blanquer c'était très clair
par son administration et vous pouvez
pas revenir sur 53 pages de de respect
sanitaire sinon vous êtes un assassin
potentiel
si vous mettez quatre pages bon on peut
essayer d appliquer à mettre une
cinquième vous passez pas de 53 pages a4
donc ça ne fonctionne pas et on voit
bien qu'à une administration qui a une
capacité aujourd'hui à produire de la
norme sans qu'elles ne l'appliquent
jamais et c'est plutôt ça la différence
et les élus locaux
il applique la norme ils en ont marre
des normes et c'est aussi un sujet qui a
été très peu évoqué peut-être on
pourrait s'arrêter un peu sur les normes
et qu'à chaque fois qu'un arrêté qu'un
décret est pris et qui concerne
collectivités locales on puisse
ah peut consulter les élus locaux et
avoir leur avis et leur feu vert avant à
la multiplication la prolifération des
normes pour le coup c'est un sujet sur
lequel le sénat proteste très souvent
mais ce que vous êtes d'accord à ce
qu'on a vu bien cette idée adaptation
finalement de l'administration de la
technocratie face à aux élus locaux
frédéric mar la technocratie et depuis
tout temps une énorme machine qu'il faut
parfois avoir même souvent contournées
pour arriver à ses fins après tout
dépend aussi on a vécu cette situation
dans le nord et je pense que ça a été le
cas dans d'autres départements
la personnalité des préfets a été aussi
déterminante avec des concertations
régulières la mise à disposition des
services des préfectures
je sais que pour le département nous
avons apprécié parfaitement le modus
operandi qui avait été mise en place par
le préfet et ses services et que bon
nombre de maires ruraux ont apprécié
avoir des réponses aux questions qu'ils
se posaient tous légitimement et d'avoir
vraiment les réponses qu'ils attendaient
mais voilà le premier ministre je pense
que c'est aussi un des chantiers sur
lesquels il va devoir son expérience
d'élu de communes rurales va sans doute
l'aider renforcer le couple maires
préfets c'est d'ailleurs une des
propositions du sénat et dans lequel on
retrouve aussi ce que voudrait faire le
gouvernement jean yves le conte
oui ça ça me semble ça me semble bien de
la même manière que je plaide pour le
renforcement des couples consul
conseiller consulaire à l'étranger on a
vu effectivement des choses de même
niveau des ddd budget qu'on va voter
alors qu'ils sont pas consommés parce
que les instructions n'ont pas été
données n'ont pas été donnés
correctement face et c'est assez
effarant de voir ça mais il ya
l'administration il faut qu'elle prenne
en compte le terrain et il faut aussi
que le ministre soit en mesure et
veulent la diriger ça n'a pas toujours
été le cas
oui jérôme bascher juste un mot je
regardais le nombre de ministres et élus
locaux ce matin au banc on n'avait pas
la moitié
j'en avais pas la moitié pour terminer
un autre passage du discours de jean
castex matin a beaucoup attiré
l'attention l'attention notamment des
réseaux sociaux c'est celui où il a
défendu le vélo et le vélo ce n'est pas
anecdotique a dit
jean castex écouter le plan de relance
portera une attention particulière aux
pistes cyclables on m'a manqué quand
j'ai dit ça on a dit il parle d'un
gadget
pas du tout mesdames et messieurs center
pas du tout pas du tout et nous sommes à
une révolution c'est le vélo électrique
il va multiplier les usages il va
multiplier les usages il va raccourcir
les distances oui oui mesdames et
messieurs oui mesdames et messieurs ne
riez pas ne riez pas dans dix ans dans
dix ans on pourra si on fait un réseau
de pistes cyclables sécurisées on pourra
aller de prades à perpignan un vélo pour
aller travailler
voilà il ya eu des sourires dans
l'hémicycle à ce moment là mais jean
yves le conte finalement jean castex on
se dit ils empruntent à la droite sur
les territoires le régalien les
retraites
et puis ils empruntent aussi à la gauche
et aux écologistes sur tout est bien
l'infection environnemental de son
discours et notamment les pistes
cyclables il a dit les pistes cyclables
c'est pas un gadget et pas seulement
pour les bobos et ben oui mais c'était
très bien maintenant il faut voir si il
arrivera le à le mettre en oeuvre et
puis la question si c'est cesser de de
faire évoluer notre tissu économique
pour que oui ils puissent profiter de
ces nouvelles opportunités
parce que moi j'entends beaucoup parler
de relance mais en même temps
concrètement les entreprises qui ont des
problèmes de trésorerie qui ont des
problèmes de marché aujourd'hui est ce
qu'on les accompagne correctement je
voyais encore ce matin là le leader en
visualisant en visualisation de nocturne
qui qui qui allait passer photonis qui
allait passer probablement sous contrôle
américain sur un sur des sujets
sensibles donc si on parle de deux
d'économie et de ses développements là
il faut aussi mettre les moyens pour que
l'économie verte
les développements et les orientations
soient réellement profitable pour
l'ensemble de notre économie et pour le
renouveau de notre industrie avec
marchands et faut des moyens
il ya eu des moyens annoncés dans le
plan de relance notamment pour la
rénovation thermique des bâtiments sur
l'ajustement la question du plan vélo
on peut y croire à cet effort en matière
d'environnement de la part de ce
gouvernement moi je vous avouerai qu'à
titre personnel j'ai bu du petit lait en
écoutant les paroles du premier ministre
puisque au moment de la discussion de la
loi d'orientation des mobilités quand
même un plan vélo dans ce pays qui
dégagent des moyens conséquents avec des
premières mises en application mais moi
je me souviens avoir proposé au
président du sénat gérard larcher la
mise en place ici dans cette maison
d'une flotte de vélos à assistance
électrique de fonction pour les
sénateurs qui nous permettrait quand on
se déplace dans des ministères qui ne
sont pas trop loin effectivement sur
paris de pouvoir utiliser des vélos des
scooters partout dans paris je me dis
qu'avec les soutiens du premier ministre
on va peut-être pouvoir aller plus loin
pour le reste en matière de transition
écologique
il y à une proposition qui est porté par
le premier ministre sur laquelle
j'attire l'attention des uns des autres
il a parlé des contrats de développement
écologique sur les territoires et faire
en sorte que tous les territoires qu'il
s'agit des régions des départements des
opci puissent être porteurs des attendus
écologique et moi je crois effectivement
dans le cadre de cette campagne des
municipales qu'on a pu voir des
différentes rencontres qu'on avec les
élus il ya une appétence de plus en plus
forte pour toutes ces questions
écologiques elle a aussi faire confiance
aux territoires me paraît être la bonne
méthode r oui jérôme bascher ça fait
sourire certains notamment à droite
cette intervention sur le plan vélo
pourquoi quand vous habitez l'ardèche
que vous n'avez pas de train
c'est le seul département de france où
il n'ya pas le train dans l'ardèche oui
oui vous déplacer en vélo connaissait ce
département un petit peu pas possible ce
n'est pas possible
quand vous habitez les alpes c'est vrai
qu'il ya pas grand monde dans les halles
mais est ce contrat d'histoire en 2001
les pistes cyclables c'est du ressort
des collectivités locales
c'est pas du ressort du premier ministre
et pas du ressort de l'état donc on peut
toujours donner des orientations et dire
aux autres ce qu'ils doivent faire
et là encore on confond les rôles donc
je suis un peu surpris on peut y mettre
les moyens lesquels dans les cpe n ont
jamais été
et réseaux les camps quand les plans le
gouvernement dans la salle à des
conférences et notamment roselyne
bachelot la ministre de la culture je
vous laisse poursuivre pour les
départements les régions et les
intercommunalités il y avait déjà un
plan climat air énergie tout ça existe
il ne se passe pas grand chose donc on
voit bien que tout ça n'est rien de neuf
orabi henry pauline et les politiques
qui existent déjà pour dire on fait des
choses les collectivités en font déjà
beaucoup moins dans mon département de
l'oise on n'a pas attendu ce discours de
politique générale pour donner une prime
de 300 euros pour l'achat d'un vélo
électrique à condition qu'ils soient
achetés dans l'oise pour un foyer fiscal
de l'oise voilà les mesures concrètes ça
sachant que le problème n'est pas
aujourd'hui même s'ils sont éteints
l'achat du vélo c'est comment on
sécurise les itinéraires pour les
cyclistes
pardon de dire que moi qui habite lille
je peux vous dire que prendre son vélo
et faire du vélo à lille
c'est vraiment comme un sport de quoi
sert président intercommunalités j'ai
fait le plus pour intercomités sur les
pistes cyclables donc je sais de quoi je
parle à julie amusant c'est bien la
preuve que ce n'est pas anecdotique
c'est bien un sujet sur lequel il ya un
réellement débat que cette question des
des vélos pour les collectivités ça
c'est un français un faux sujet toutes
les collectivités s'achemine cet usage
on a des exemples de succès quand même
notamment à paris même si les
automobilistes le regrette évidemment on
voit que le vélo c'est un mode de
transport d'affiner ses modes de
transport en de santé c'est un mode de
transport qui est plébiscité par celles
et ceux qui ont la possibilité
d'utiliser ce qui n'est évidemment pas
possible partout
je pense que la main sur un sujet
effectivement l'état
gouvernement souhaite encourager la
pratique du vélo c'est les collectivités
qui doivent émettre honneur à tout ça me
paraît me paraît très très logique et
qui voit pas de sujet par contre je
voudrais revenir sur ce qu'a dit
monsieur marchand sur l'administration
et sur la mise en oeuvre de ces
politiques qui encore une fois me paraît
être au coeur du problème notamment vous
avez dit que c'est que les
administrations sont parfois une grosse
machine qu'il faut contourner certains
peuvent contourner les grosses machines
d'autres ne peuvent pas contourner les
grosses machines tant qu'on considère
que les administrations sont des grosses
machines qu'il faut contourner
on aura un problème quand on considérait
des administrations qui travaillent pour
les aînés qui travaillent pour les
ministres déjà comme des grosses
machines à contourner me paraît
problématique est par ailleurs les
usagers n'ont pas les moyens n'ont pas
le temps non pas la reconnaissance non
pas la ressource pour contourner toutes
ces administrations les préfectures les
services déconcentrés de l'état qui
effectivement ne sont pas nécessairement
toujours réactif est d'ailleurs le
premier ministre l'a rappelé il a dit
que meta et le gouvernement devra faire
preuve d'humilité sur ces sujets donc je
je persévère dès qu'il ya vraiment un
chantier très important de notre
transformation de rénovation a mené de
modernisation très forte très rapide on
voit bien aujourd'hui qu'on ait un
décalage ce décalage se manifeste pour
les élus locaux comme pour les citoyens
avec des difficultés pour avoir des
réponses rapides des réponses fiables
des réponses même parfois tout court
et donc ce sujet
les paroles et des actes pour voir avant
lors de ce prochain gouvernement
un grand chantier qui s'ouvre un pour
les ch'ti 100 prochains jours tandis que
l'on voit arriver
gérard larcher le président du sénat
il va aller dans le cabinet de départ
alors que la séance des questions
d'actualité au gouvernement va commencer
maintenant dans six minutes très
exactement
auparavant on a également vu arriver le
porte-parole du gouvernement
gabriella talent et tout de suite on va
rejoindre salle des conférences
alexandre pousse à alexandre vous êtes
avec la présidente du la présente us et
de la commission de la culture catherine
morin desailly car elle va tout à
l'heure interpeller le gouvernement
oui une question au gouvernement sur la
protection de nos données personnelles
alors en quoi ça consiste et bien une
décision de la justice européenne vient
d'annuler en accord avec les états unis
qui autorise le transfert de nos données
personnelles nous utilisateurs européens
vers les entreprises du numérique
américaine alors catherine morin
desailly est ce que cet accord annulé
c'est une bonne décision
oui parce que nous n'avons aucune
garantie aujourd'hui qu'il n'y ait pas
intrusion des services de renseignement
américains dans nos données les données
des européens qui peuvent être
transférées sur un jour sur fédérale aux
états unis par les sociétés américaines
qui gère ces données des fameuses gars
femmes
vous savez alors ça veut dire que
l'union européenne conclut des accords
avec les états unis pour soi disant
protéger nos données personnelles mais
en réalité elles sont mises en danger
oui de longue date depuis la sphère
snowdon c'était le ses formes avant il a
été annulé à cause de ce qu'a révélé
edouard snowdon sur l'espionnage de nos
données on avait tenté depuis quelques
années à travers le privacy chili et le
bouclier de protection des données de
rétablir un accord mais cet accord est
toujours bancal il est toujours
insuffisant donc nous ne sommes pas
protégés
raison de plus pour militer pour notre
souveraineté numérique et européennes
raison de plus pour demander ce que je
vais demander au ministre de la santé
que la plateforme des données de santé
constitué à l'automne dernier dans des
conditions un peu opaque a pas eu
d'appel d'offres ne soit pas confié un
gars femmes pas confié à microsoft mais
à une entreprise française et européenne
qui nous garantira un niveau de
protection suffisant alors c'est
d'autant plus important qu'on est en
période de crise sanitaire ça veut dire
que nous donner de santé là elles sont
dans les mains d'un géant du numérique
et elles ne sont pas les oui et oui
c'est ça qui se profile alors c'est en
plus du
du long terme c'est une plateforme
structurantes qui dans les années à
venir va conduire nos politiques
publiques de santé ce sont des données
extrêmement sensible aux données de
santé je dirai les choses à redire des
données de l'éducation la même
problématique a surgi à quelques années
dans les données d'éducation on avait
contractualiser avec google et microsoft
sans appel d'offres j'avais alerté à
l'époque le ministre de l'éducation il y
aujourd'hui sensible mais il faut une
cohérence gouvernementale sur ce sujet
d'autant que le cadre européen montre
bien les juristes européens nous alerte
sur ce sujet donc raison de plus pour
faire particulièrement attention et vous
parlez de cadre européen pourtant et
bien on a voté ici au parlement un
règlement européen de protection de nos
données nous donner ça veut dire
qu'elles sont très bien protégées au
niveau européen mais à l'étranger elles
sont toujours hors de l'union elles sont
c'est insuffisant d'angel vous le dis à
l'heure actuelle le gouvernement fédéral
aux états unis peu sur injonction se
procurer les données des européens donc
il faut aujourd'hui un cadre législatif
nouveau qui soit bien important et qui
permettent pour moi ce qu'on appelle
data residency qui est la localisation
en europe de nos données et la gestion
et leur traitement par des entreprises
européennes
voilà ce qu'il faut aujourd'hui
revendiquer catherine morin desailly ont
fini par évoquer un autre géant du
numérique apple dont la demande pour ces
avantages fiscaux accordés par l'ira par
l'irlande son amende de 13 milliards
d'euros a été annulé par la justice
européenne
on est en train encore une fois de
perdre la bataille face aux géants du
numérique et je le regrette très
profondément parce que les gérants du
numérique ces fameuses gars femmes ont
abusé fiscalement ne se sont pas
acquittés de l'impôt alors qu'ils
captaient toute la valeur ajoutée ces
dernières années des contenus tout
produisons sur les réseaux sociaux et à
partir de leurs plateformes
d'hébergement
ils ont abusé en matière de concurrence
abus de position dominante d'un google
et ils ont abusé démocratiquement ils
ont cherché à manipuler nos élections
c'est la sphère cambridge analytica très
bien merci beaucoup catherine morin
desailly pour votre intervention qui
montre que la bataille avec les gens du
numérique n'est pas encore gagné oui
merci à beaucoup à l'exemple pour cette
interview catherine morin desailly qui
donc posera une question sur la
protection des données de santé ça sera
à olivier ferrand le ministre des
solidarités de la santé que l'on a
d'ailleurs vu arriver
masqué salle des conférences merci
beaucoup messieurs d'avoir participé à
ce débat sur et bien ce discours que
l'on a pu entendre aujourd'hui de jean
castex le premier ministre à qui il
reste donc du pain sur la planche pour
les 600 prochains jours merci beaucoup
et tout de suite on va rejoindre
alexandre poussard salle des conférences
car vous êtes avec jean raymond hugonnet
jean raymond et gones et sénateurs les
républicains qui va lui aussi interrogé
le gouvernement interpellé le
gouvernement autour de ce cette affaire
sur ce pompier blessé par balle à
étampes
en essonne sur son territoire oui une
question de jean emond hugonnet sur
cette tentative d'homicide contre un
pompier du département de l'essonne dans
les dents en marge des événements du 14
juillet qu'elle est d'abord votre
sentiment après cette agression
sentiment de grande révolte et un
sentiment aussi j'ai été très choqué par
l'intervention du président de la
république le 14 juillet qui a grillé la
politesse au premier ministre lors de
son discours de politique générale pas
un mot sur la sécurité la sécurité ce
n'est pas un gros mot
aujourd'hui les français ont bien
compris que le pays va à vau l'eau
on tue ici des gendarmes ici des
chauffeurs de bus une tentative
d'homicide sur un pompier par derrière
en plus dans le dos c'est totalement
insupportable et nous sommes tous
révoltés par de tels comportements alors
l'une des réponses du ministre de
l'intérieur a notamment après cette
agression d'un pompier c'était que
l'état désormais portera plainte
systématiquement contre les auteurs de
ces agressions est-ce que c'est
suffisant cette réponse alors messieurs
dames darmanin est un homme d'action
c'est un élu local qui c'est l'action il
partage et je sais je sais que c'est un
homme d'action
la première déclaration bien entendu
le remercions d'être de cette transporté
sur les lieux hier soir à 19h au côté de
franck marlin maire d'étampés
c'est un signe qui ne trompe pas en
revanche le dépôt de plainte
systématique on peut s'étonner que ça
soit pas déjà le cas
c'est quand même un strict minimum
aujourd'hui on attend autre chose
ce qui tue qui pillent et qui foule aux
pieds la nation française doivent être
traités comme il se doit
c'est à dire on doit les mettre hors
d'état de nuire est ce que pour vous il
faut renforcer notamment la réponse
pénale face à ce type d'agression contre
des symboles de la république c'est une
évidence
c'est une évidence et là dessus on
attend le garde des sceaux maître
dupond-moretti
parce que
la sécurité sans la justice c'est à dire
les pouvoirs régaliens de l'état
eh bien ça ne fonctionnera jamais il y a
un énorme chantier sur la table et pour
l'instant on n'a pas l'impression qu'ils
ont vraiment encore un lien notamment
entre gérald darmanin eric dupond
moretti sur cette réponse pénale
apportée
très honnêtement je crois qu'il faut
leur laisser peut-être un petit peu le
temps de l'installation ils viennent
d'arriver
mais en tout cas ils en ont conscience
d'après leurs dires
ici dans l'hémicycle ils ont conscience
que c'est vraiment deux maillons de la
chaîne qui doivent être intimement liés
alors on a beaucoup en tout cas critiqué
ici dans l'hémicycle du sénat
parfois les positions christophe
castaner le ministre de l'intérieur face
aux forces de l'ordre
est-ce que vous avez le sentiment que le
nouveau gouvernement et plus solidaire
de ses forces de l'ordre
ils sont républicains
ce darmanin l'a dit l'état la république
doit être partout donc bien entendu qu'a
priori il l'a maintenant ce sont les
faits que nous voulons voir assez de
paroles assez de tweets assez de
rodomontades ici il faut des faits merci
jean raymond ligonnet la cloche de
gérard larcher vient d'être sonné c'est
le début de ces questions d'actualité au
gouvernement en direct sur public sénat
une heure un peu inhabituel j'appelle
chacun de mes collègues a observé au
cours de nos échanges d'une des valeurs
essentielles du sénat le respect respect
des uns et des autres et aussi respect
du temps de parole et je renouvelle mes
recommandations en matière sanitaire les
uns à côté des autres sinon de porter un
masque si vous êtes d un côté les autres
et la sortie de par l'arrière pour les
membres du sénat et par le devant pour
le gouvernement
je vais donner la parole à madame
françoise cartron pour le groupe de la
république en marche
merci
monsieur président ma question s'adresse
à madame la ministre de la transition
écologique d'ici à la fin de 2021
nous souhaitons que tous les territoires
je dis bien tous soient dotés de
contrats de développement écologique
avec des plans d'action concrets
chiffres et mesurables c'est ce que vous
avez annoncé monsieur le premier
ministre hier à l'assemblée nationale
et ce matin au sénat votre gouvernement
acte 20 milliards d'euros pour la
croissance écologique dans l'optique de
gagner la bataille pour le climat et la
biodiversité afin que les ducs onomie
française devienne la plus verte et la
plus décarbonés d'europe
parmi les objectifs produire une
alimentation plus local et durable
il y a une dizaine de jours ici même
nous en débattions sur la base du
rapport que nous avons rendu fin mai
avec mon collègue jean luc fichet et
dans ce rapport de nombreuses
propositions pour une transition réussie
réussi parmi les objectifs également
soutenir les technologies vertes de
demain mieux recycler moins gaspiller
une politique de vélo ambitieuse est
également à mettre en place et à cela il
convient d'ajouter le plan de relance
envers l'industrie avec des
contreparties afin de faire évoluer
notre modèle de production
madame la ministre quelle sera la place
des collectivités et des mères aux
particuliers dans ses politiques
d'avenir
quel cahier des charges pour les
contrats de développement écologique
avec quel financement quelle
complémentarité entre les collectivités
et l'état pour porter ces politiques
d'avenir ici comme en gironde comme
partout en france les actions sur
comment mieux manger mieux circuler
mieux respirer sont au coeur de notre
vie quotidienne
plébiscité par nos concitoyennes et nos
concitoyens la crise nous l'a rappelé
très fortement
nous devons y répondre pour vous
répondre à parler
cabanas mme barbe à la barbara pompili
ministre de la transition écologique
vous avez la parole merci merci monsieur
le président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs madame la sénatrice cartron
merci pour votre question et merci
effectivement pour l'excellent travail
que vous avez fait avec votre collègue
qui nous qui nous servira j'en suis
certaine
le premier ministre l'a dit d'ici 2021
donc tous les territoires devront être
dotés d'un contrat de relance et de
développement écologique tous les
territoires c'est à dire tous les
bassins de vie et c'est ça qui est
important alors il ya déjà des outils
qui existent nationaux locaux action
coeur de ville territoire d'industrie
contrat de ruralité et cetera mon
ministère a d'autre part porter le
développement des contrats de transition
écologique 107 territoire 250 pci ont
déjà signé et sur la base de me
d'actions concrètes c'est plus de 1,5
milliard d'euros qui ont été mobilisés
maintenant l'idée c'est d'accélérer le
déploiement est d'associer tout le monde
c'est à dire que sur sur ces contrats il
faut que toutes les populations soient
associés les jeunes également les
entreprises les associations les élus
bien évidemment et l'idée ces contrats
c'est qu'il soit globaux sur tous les
sujets qui permette de relancer
l'activité sur le territoire dans le
sens de la transition écologique
donc là on parle évidemment de
l'urbanisme
on parle du vélo par exemple on parle
des réseaux d'eau on parle de delà des
réflexions des bâtiments etc etc
l'adduction d'électricité dans l'est
dans les territoires ruraux qui en ont
besoin
c'est vraiment sûr tous ces aspects
qu'il faut qu'on se réunisse et
comportant un schéma global une vision
globale concrètes et l'etat sera
évidemment à vos côtés il y a aussi des
outils pour vous aider notamment la
haine s'était par exemple qui a été mise
en place et qui peut apporter
l'ingénierie pour les territoires qui en
ont besoin et à ce stade je tiens à
saluer le travail qui a déjà été fait
d'abord par ma collègue jacqueline
gourault sur sur ces questions mais
aussi par sébastien lecornu et
emmanuelle wargon qui ont fait un très
beau travail et je vais continuer avec
les manuels
à vous aider sur les territoires pour
que les réalisations concrètes soient
mises en place
merci la parole est maintenant aux
présidents jean marc gabouty pour le
groupe du rassemblement démocratique et
social européen avait la parole merci
monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse aussi à madame barbara pompili
mis la transition écologique ya monsieur
jean baptiste jebbari ministre délégué
chargé des transports
une politique de modernisation des
infrastructures de transport au service
de l'aménagement du territoire et de la
protection de l'environnement doit être
intégrée au programme d'investissements
publics de notre pays pour la prochaine
décennie
il faut rendre compatibles et
complémentaires le développement
économique d'écologie et le
désenclavement des territoires
la mutation des modes de transport en
est un élément majeur à côté du
transport routier auquel il manque
quelques maillons du transport fluvial
qui doit être accéléré le canal seine
nord europe a pris beaucoup de retard se
pose la problématique du transport
ferroviaire qui constitue un levier
essentiel de l'accessibilité des
territoires et de la démarche écologique
celle ci étant parfois trop souvent à
mon sens dogmatique punitive ou
cosmétiques
c'est bien sûr le transport de voyageurs
qui à l'exception de la grande vitesse
se trouve pour les intercités et les
petites lignes évoqué ce matin par
monsieur le premier ministre en matière
d'équipement un d'offres commerciales à
un niveau très dégradé voire ubuesque
je parle par exemple du train jour/nuit
paris rodez qui restent stationnés à
00h03 heure et demie en gare de brive
plus grave encore le fret ferroviaire
connaît une régression continue depuis
plusieurs décennies
au niveau national la part modale du fer
et du fleuve atteint aujourd'hui 9 % du
tonnage contre 46% en 1974 la moyenne
européenne étant de 17% cette faiblesse
structurelle se caractérise par
l'abandon de desserte industrielle aussi
bien en termes d'approvisionnement que
d'expédition et par l'affaiblissement de
la capacité logistique de nos activités
portuaires en termes de fret ferroviaire
y compris pour le ferroutage nous sommes
à la traîne de l'europe dans un domaine
pourtant créateurs d'emplois et
hautement stratégique dans la lutte
contre le réchauffement climatique
monsieur le ministre le gouvernement est
il prêt à lancer sur dix ans un plan
marshall ferroviaire
nécessitant plusieurs dizaines de
milliards d'investissements pour
remettre notre pays à niveau et permet
de dégager une offre de service plus
compétitive et plus écologique pour vous
répondre la parole mais comme ce
ministre délégué en charge des
transports monsieur djebbari vous avez
la parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur
sénateurs rugby abouti merci pour cette
question importante cher évidemment aux
territoires et singulièrement aux nôtres
je voulais vous dire vous savez que ce
gouvernement depuis 2007 a investi très
massivement dans les transports pour
vous l'avez dit désenclaver nos
territoires pour verdir et transport et
cela a conduit à mobiliser plus de 13
milliards d'euros sur l'ensemble du
quinquennat qui porte à la fois sur les
travaux d'entretien de régénération et
de développement des infrastructures
nécessaires à l'ensemble du territoire
en métropole ou en outre-mer des
premiers actes importants ont été posées
je pense notamment aux protocoles petite
ligne et vous devez avoir en mémoire que
nous avons signé le 20 janvier dernier
les premiers protocoles avec les région
grand est et centre val de loire je ne
doute pas que d'autres régions suivront
nous investissons de manière inédite
dans la régénération du réseau routier
et nous avons voulu préserver les lignes
aériennes d'aménagement du territoire
avec une philosophie qui consiste à
mieux articuler les modes de transport
en entre eux pour répondre aux
spécificités des territoires aux besoins
de leurs habitants et de leur entreprise
et garantir ainsi et vous l'avez
souligné leur attractivité
nous allons encore accéléré le président
de la république le premier ministre ont
l'occasion de s'exprimer
récemment les transports seront au coeur
du plan de relance
nous poursuivrons la contractualisation
avec l'ambition de sauver les 9000
kilomètres de petites lignes
ferroviaires nous voulons créer de
nouvelles lignes de trains de nuit vous
avez parlé effectivement de cette ligne
importante qui passe par brive et par
rodez notamment et nous ambitionnons de
doubler la part modale du fret
ferroviaire encore effectivement trop
faible dans notre pays nous aurons
l'occasion d'annoncer la création de
nouvelles autoroutes ferroviaires
prochainement ses projets mais ceux-ci
nature ont vocation à se déployer d'ici
à la fin du quinquennat et plusieurs
milliards ils seront alloués nous avons
je conclus par sa beaucoup d'ambitions
pour les transports ils sont
à la fois pourvoyeur d'emplois non des
non délocalisables et eric de nos
territoires
ils ont au coeur du développement
économique et écologique que nous
portons pour notre pays merci à paroles
et à leurs collègues esther benbassa
pour le groupe communiste républicain
citoyen écologie ce monsieur le
président madame la ministre de la
transition écologique
mes chers collègues la convention
citoyenne pour le climat créé à
l'initiative du président macron à
formuler 149 proposition le chef de
l'état avait promis leur transcription
dans la loi dès le 29 juin il annonçait
pourtant qu'au moins trois d'entre elles
ne seraient pas retenus
donc la taxe de 4 % sur les dividendes
et pourtant point d'écologie sans
solidarité ni justice sociale le
lendemain
madame agnès panière une hache est
révélé que le moratoire demandé sur la
5g luxe énergivores bien inutile dans un
pays où l'internet ne décèle même pas la
totalité des territoires n'était pas non
plus envisager le 14 juillet le
président macron a certes parlé
d'écologie
il est vrai que ce thème semble
aujourd'hui pourvoyeur de voix en ont
fait des mesures déjà envisagé dès 2018
comme par exemple la rénovation
thermique des écoles et pat c'est faire
du neuf avec du vieux en revanche
combien de petites lignes ferroviaires
sauver combien de tonnes de fret
ferroviaire en plus dit nous il ne
s'agit pas d'opposer croissance
écologique à des croissance verte mais
de l'impérieuse nécessité de changer de
modèle social et économique accor le
référendum inscrivant dans la
constitution la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique et la
protection de la biodiversité
à quand le projet de loi validant les
propositions de la convention
ferez vous en 600 jours ce que vous
n'avez pas fait en trois ans mercy
pour nous répond de la parole et à
madame la ministre de transition
écologique des propylées
merci merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice esther benbassa pas
de transition écologique sans justice
sociale c'est une évidence et vous
pouvez compter sur moi pour y veiller et
pourrait pour réveiller avec le reste du
gouvernement qui est également sur cette
ligne la convention citoyenne pour le
climat ce sont des citoyens qui au
départ n'était pas sensibilisé à la
question écologique qui ont travaillé
longtemps qu'ils se sont renseignés et
qui ont fait des propositions qui pour
certaines d'entre elles vont même
au-delà de ce que propose des
écologistes depuis longtemps le
président de la république s'est engagé
à aller transcrire donc deux différentes
manières puisque vous savez puisque vous
avez lu ces propositions qu'il y en a
certaines qui sont du domaine
réglementaire
celles ci feront l'objet d'un prochain
conseil de défense écologique qui
déterminera comment on applique ces
mesures d'ordre réglementaire
il y en a d'autres qui sont qui relève
d'engagement et de négociations
internationales et le président a eu
l'occasion de commencer à les porter
lors de sa rencontre avec la chancelière
merkel et dans les heures qui ont suivi
sa rencontre avec les citoyens il y en a
d'autres qui relèvent des collectivités
locales et donc évidemment les
collectivités locales seront associés
avec les citoyens à la transposition de
ces mesures parce que l'idée c'est pas
de faire ça d'en haut c'est de
travailler avec les élus pour qu'on
puisse apporter des solutions sur les
territoires que proposent les citoyens
et enfin il vient des mesures d'ordre
législatif
effectivement et nous avons décidé de
garder toujours la même méthode
nous allons monter un groupe de travail
avec marc fesneau qui avait associé les
parlementaires donc les sénateurs les
députés mais aussi les citoyens pour
aboutir un projet de loi qui sera déposé
à la fin de l'été et qui nous permettra
certainement de le faire passer au plus
tôt vers vers des bus 2021 après
l'exercice budgétaire
voilà donc on va les réaliser ces
propositions est évidemment j'ajoute
parce qu'il nous reste dix sept secondes
que le premier ministre a annoncé ce
matin que 30 % des montants du plan de
relance allaient être investis dans la
transition écologique et je peux vous
dire que là dedans on va retrouver
beaucoup de ce qui est proposé par les
citoyens qui seront financés on avait
besoin de financement on
maintenant c'est une très bonne chose et
nous allons pouvoir les réaliser madame
benbassa pour quelques secondes des
actes madame la ministre des actes nous
attendons des actes pas des paroles
parce que nous avons eu assez de paroles
merci parole est maintenant à madame
muriel cabaret pour le groupe socialiste
et républicain
je voudrais saluer cette première prise
de parole dans nos questions de notre
collègue qui merci monsieur le président
ma question s'adresse au premier
ministre en votre âme et conscience vous
avez nommé nommé gérald darmanin
ministre de l'intérieur pourtant
celui-ci fait à nouveau l'objet d'une
enquête en cours pour viol harcèlement
et abus de confiance concernant une
sombre affaire d' échange de faveurs
sexuelles contre une intervention à la
chancellerie depuis 2017
nous avons vu nombre de ministres
démissionner suite à des affaires pistes
fiscales financières ou encore
consommation intempestives de marc
mêlant ce cas précis rien circulez ya
rien à voir rien à comprendre
il n'y a pas de problème avec le
président vous affichez votre soutien
sans faille au ministre de l'intérieur
sans même attendre la fin de la
procédure judiciaire c'est une erreur
éthique politique d'une violence
symbolique
inouï que nous dit vous en réalité que
monsieur darmanin est innocent que la
victime mans au mépris des principes
d'équité du contradictoire et d'
équilibre entre les parties
pire vous ignorez le conflit d'intérêts
en puissance
que représente cette nomination que se
passera-t-il dans le cas d'une mise en
examen d'un ministre qui sera l'autorité
hiérarchique des policiers chargés de
l'enquêté sur les agissements que les
députés lrm se rassurent nous il ne
s'agit pas de nier la présomption
d'innocence
nous y sommes très attachés
mais de vous interroger sur le signal
délétère envoyé à toutes les victimes
vous qui en a fait avec son plat rites
et de la politique et à la lutte contre
les violences faites aux femmes
quel message envoyé vous aux françaises
et aux français
lorsque vous faites fi de la parole des
victimes mesurez-vous bien les
conséquences de cette nomination
pour vous répondre la parole est à
monsieur le premier ministre monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs madame la sénatrice
je comprends que c'est votre première
intervention
je vais vous dire madame je vais vous
dire madame vous m'avez dit vous
défendez monsieur darmanin c'est pas
monsieur darmanin que je déforme
ce sont les principes fondamentaux de
l'état de droit
je suis ici je suis ici chef du
gouvernement dans une assemblée
parlementaire dans une assemblée
parlementaire
monsieur darmanin n'est pas mis en
examen
monsieur darmanin n'a fait l'objet
d'aucune condamnation et à ce que je
sache
à chaque fois que l'autorité judiciaire
a eu à se prononcer dans cette affaire
elle a rendu des actes consacre à
l'innocence de monsieur darmanin
monsieur darmanin a droit au respect des
principes de la république comme tous
les citoyens comme tous les citoyens
nous assistons nous assistons à des
dérives qui sont inadmissibles
je le dis ici avec solennité et gravité
j'ajoute j'ajoute comme vous le savez
qu'il m'appartient
aux termes de la constitution de
proposer au président la république à la
faveur de la constitution du
gouvernement
les propositions visant tu as la
constitution de ce dernier c'est donc en
mon âme et conscience
madame au delà au delà du respect des
principes fondamentaux de la république
que j'ai fait cette proposition
votre intervention madame suppose donc
que j'aurais biaiser avec ma conscience
et ça je ne vous autorise pas à le dire
je vous remercie madame cabaret vous
avez cateau
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
joël guerriau pour le groupe les
indépendants merci monsieur présent
monsieur le ministre
malgré de belles avancées la situation
du sel reste très préoccupante
d'abord parce que nous y avons déjà
atteint un objectif c'est l'élimination
du chef de l'aqmi
mais pour autant on l'a vu dans des
événements récents de ce week-end les
maliens se manifeste sa colère anti
gouvernementales la france a beaucoup
investi sur le mali en particulier je
voudrais ici rendre hommage aux
militaires français qui ont été blessées
ou tuées au cours de ces opérations nous
ont payé un lourd tribut nous avons donc
une vigilance particulière apportée sur
ces territoires
le g5 sahel est un soutien fondamental
est au coeur du g5 crs se trouve le mali
qui est une puissance regroupant un
territoire très vaste
alors monsieur le ministre c'est
derniers jours des manifestations ont
réuni une foule considérable sur la
capitale bamako
il ya eu des incidents très violent et
sanglant puisqu'il ya eu 11 morts et
plus de 150 blessés
une situation dramatique où le
gouvernement est remis en cause en
particulier suite aux élections
législatives de mars et avril
donc nous sommes en droit de nous
inquiéter parce que nous on besoin d'un
état fort et légitime pour mener à bien
ces lutte antiterroriste alors ma
question monsieur le ministre est très
simple est ce que d'abord ressortissants
français qui sont nombreux au mali sont
en toute sécurité
et puis surtout qu'est ce que la
communauté internationale peut faire
pour éviter que le mali tourner dans le
chaos avec un risque de renversement du
gouvernement soit par un groupe
terroriste ou bien encore un risque
d'une autre nature qui serait un état
militaire
merci monsieur liste pour vous répondre
la parole et co ministre délégué chargé
du commerce extérieur monsieur franck
riester vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames les
sénatrices monsieur messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur gayraud
d'abord je tiens à excuser jean yves le
drian qui est
ne pouvaient pas être présents cet après
midi ici au sénat puisqu'il était en
déplacement à l'étranger vous avez
raison le mali traverse une crise
politique qui a conduit ce week-end à
des débordements grave qui d'ailleurs
ont été réprimées avec usage de la force
manifestement excessive la france a
condamné clairement les débordements de
toutes parts et appelle les différentes
parties à retrouver le chemin du
dialogue
la france est bien sûr aux côtés de ses
ressortissants à travers son ambassade
pour assurer leur sécurité et aux côtés
des partenaires internationaux pour
appuyer une solution d'avenir
nous sommes évidemment derrière toutes
les initiatives des forces politiques et
sociales qui conduirait à retrouver le
chemin du dialogue le président keita
s'est adressé à la nation et a pris un
certain nombre d'engagements et la
france encourage le président quitte à
mettre en oeuvre les engagements qu'il a
pris notamment d'abroger le décret de
nomination des membres de la cour
constitutionnelle de constituer un
gouvernement de consensus d'ailleurs le
premier ministre cissé y travaillent
nous pouvons noter aussi avec
satisfaction que celles et ceux qui
avaient été arrêtés lors des
débordements ont été libérés nous
appelons le président keita continuer
dans cet esprit de responsabilité et
bien sûr nous soutenons la mission de la
cedeao qui après ses fortes de la
première mission dans toutes les
formules et préconisations été rendu au
moins de juin mène une nouvelle mission
qui devrait nous permettre de proposer
des solutions d'avenir pour le mali
merci monsieur gerioù
extrêmement attentif à ce qui se passe
au mali hier encore il ya eu sept
villageois dogon qui ont été tuées par
des terroristes d'où l'importance de la
présence française
mais encore une fois je crains que le
gouvernement ait montré une certaine
fragilité et il serait bon que ib cas
reviennent dans un chemin démocratique
parfaitement qui légitimera parfaitement
son pouvoir merci merci la parole et à
notre collègue jean raymond hugonnet
pour le groupe l'est républicain
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur mardi soir il est 23h30 sur
le petit parking du stade laloyaux à
étampes
en essonne département que j'ai
l'honneur de représenter ici avec quatre
autres de mes collègues
un sapeur pompiers qui intervenaient sur
un incendie de voiture a été la cible
d'un tir par arme à feu
voyant une balle lui traverser le mollet
notre collègue franck marlin maire
d'étampés présents sur les lieux au
moment de cette véritable tentative
d'homicide pourrait égrainé les actes
d'incivilité de violences urbaines
insupportables dont sa ville est victime
depuis tant d'années à l'instar de très
nombreuses villes de france
vous étiez hier sur place à ses côtés
pour témoigner de votre soutien aux
soldats du feu ainsi qu'à l'ensemble des
forces de l'ordre et nous vous en
remercions monsieur le ministre je vous
sais homme d'action et de responsabilité
mais au delà du dépôt de plainte
systématique que vous avez appelez de
vos voeux hier ce qui constitue
reconnaissons le un strict minimum
comment comptez vous sortir de la
posture des tweets et des discours creux
auquel votre prédécesseur nous a
malheureusement trop souvent habitué
durant cette triste première moitié du
quinquennat
vous avez déclaré hier la république est
partout chez elle assurément monsieur le
ministre
elle est partout chez elle alors comment
comptez-vous mettre hors d'état de nuire
ceux qui n'ont pas cette idée de la
france que nous avons en partage et qui
est en notre fierté nationale
en d'autres termes
quand comment comptez-vous sortir la
france de la chienlit dans laquelle elle
se trouve plongée pour vous répondre la
parole et à monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs face aux
sénateurs
si vous avez raison hier soir auprès des
élus de l'essonne
je suis allé rendre visite à ceux
sapeurs-pompiers et aux camarades de sa
brigade pour leur dire évidemment
l'émotion qu'a suscitée non pas simple
fait divers
mais cette attaque contre la république
contre des sapeurs-pompiers qui portent
l'uniforme de la solidarité est
effectivement dont l'un d'eux a été
touché par balle lors d'une intervention
somme toute banale d'éteindre un
incendie de véhicule sera parking
ce qui est encore plus choquant monsieur
le sénateur c'est que ce sergent chef a
connu pour la troisième fois en dix mois
une agression comme beaucoup de ses
camarades comme beaucoup de ses
camarades de l'essonne mais finalement
le sait bien de beaucoup de villes de
france
il connaît tous les jours désormais
lorsqu'il intervient alors qu'il est là
pour aider les autres et c'est sa
vocation et qu'ils soient professionnels
ou volontaires
la peur au ventre lorsqu'il est en
intervention
j'ai annoncé à la demande du premier
ministre effectivement désormais le
dépôt de plainte systématique au nom de
l'administration
en plus de ce que fera ce sapeur pompier
j'ai évoqué avec monsieur le préfet
département et les forces de police sa
façon dont on pourrait encore plus
protégés bien sûr les pompiers on en est
arrivé là monsieur le sénateur vous le
savez bien dans des interventions que
l'on pourrait qualifier de très
difficile mais j'aurais surtout dire que
en attaquant les pompiers en attaquant
les policiers en attaquant les gendarmes
en attaquant aussi ce conducteur de bus
qui a été tuée dans des façons
particulièrement ignoble à bayonne en
attaquant les professeurs aussi les
médecins les infirmiers et les
infirmières on attaque la république la
république et des partout chez elle et
elle est attaquée tout ne sera pas réglé
en un jour
la société vous le savez monsieur le
sénateur dans certains endroits de la
république je sais de quoi je parle pour
avoir été élu local dans un territoire
que l'on peut qualifier parfois de
difficile et aujourd'hui
mis en joue et bien la volonté du
gouvernement de jean katell jean castex
et du président de la république c'est
une pas seulement des mots monsieur le
sénateur vous avez raison mais c'est
bien sûr des actes et je serai partout
là où on pourra faire reculer ce qu'ils
veulent que nous reculons je venais
monsieur le ministre je gens avec
beaucoup de responsabilités bien sûr la
république est attaquée mais plus que la
république monsieur le ministre c'est la
nation qui est attaqué et il va bien
falloir que ce gouvernement montre ce
qui n'a jamais été montré ce qu'ils sont
pour cette nation ou ceux qui sont
contre cette nation et qui n'ont plus
rien à voir avec notre société
républicaine
merci la parole est à madame la
présidente catherine morin desailly pour
le groupe de l'union centriste en vie
dans ma question s'adresse au ministre
de la santé il ya quelques semaines lors
des débats sur la loi d'urgence
sanitaire je vous interrogeait tout
comme votre collègue cédric haut sur les
raisons qui ont conduit le gouvernement
à choisir microsoft un gars femmes pour
gérer les données de santé recueillies
par la plateforme stats à 1
une décision prise à l'automne 2010 neuf
dans des conditions opaques dénoncé par
un collectif d'experts sans appel
d'offres au détriment de toute
entreprise française ou européenne
la réponse de cédric au argumentant
qu'il n'y avait aucune entreprise
française capable de répondre aux
exigences techniques a été pour le moins
édifiante elle a d'ailleurs soulevé
beaucoup de protestation dans les jours
qui ont suivi depuis les débats vont bon
train et je me réjouis qu'il y ait une
prise de conscience y compris dans les
rangs de votre majorité de menace
sérieuse pour notre souveraineté
je note que lors de la conférence de
pressse top cow vide vous avez du coup
annoncé un nouvel appel d'offres à cette
occasion le directeur de l'anssi a
fortement suggéré de sélectionner des
entreprises ayant leur siège en europe
la présidente de la cnil ne dit pas
mieux dans les avis formulés depuis mon
goût j'aimerais connaître le calendrier
de cet appel d'offres et les conditions
d'élaboration de son cahier des charges
devant permettre à des entreprises
françaises de bâtir cette plateforme et
ne pas dépendre de sociétés américaines
nous soumettant ainsi une législation
étrangère peu protectrice
en l'état monsieur le ministre deux
questions fondamentales qui attendent
des réponses politique et non technique
oui ou non les données des françaises
ont-elles un actif stratégique majeur
auquel cas elle le sort est remise entre
les mains d'acteurs étrangers
oui ou non va-t-on se doter enfin d'une
politique industrielle offensive
permettant d'accompagner nos entreprises
et appliquer la préférence communautaire
comme ont su le faire les américains
crée en l'écosystème que nous
connaissons dans lequel nous vivons
aujourd'hui pour vous répondre
la parole est à venice des solidarités
de la santé monsieur olivier v rende la
parole madame la sénatrice morin
desailly jour merci pour cette question
comme je vous remercie pour
l'implication que vous mettez dans ce
dossier fondamental
j'ai lu d'ailleurs dans la presse
dernièrement une interview et je
m'attendais à cette question quand j'ai
vu que vous alliez m'interroger ça m'a
permis de travailler un peu le sujet
puisque comme vous l'avez souligné vous
même
c'est une décision qui a été prise bien
avant mon arrivée mais dont je suis
évidemment par essence même solidaires
néanmoins vous soulevez le souligne
soulever quelques questions
fondamentales
première question vous me posez est ce
que les données de santé sont un enjeu
de souveraineté
est ce que c'est important la réponse
est évidemment oui et je n'ai pas passé
ici quelques journées et quelques nuits
à débattre de ce top qu'ovide contacts
qu vis des autres applications pour vous
dire aujourd'hui le contraire les
données de santé sont absolument
essentiels dans leur exploitation dans
leur partage dans leur sécurisation et
ces données doivent évidemment rester de
gestion et de sécurisation française
deuxième question que vous posez quand
serons nous à la hauteur si je comprends
bien si je résume des américains ou
d'autres puissances tytgat femmes dans
la capacité à développer du numérique
madame la sénatrice vous le savez comme
moi et personne ici n'est plus
responsable qu'un autre la france
investit ces dernières années quelques
centaines de millions d'euros dans les
techniques du technologies du numérique
là où les états unis investissent
plusieurs de dizaines de milliards de
dollars par an sur la même période
c'est un enjeu majeur et cédric hauck et
secrétaires d'état qui était secrétaire
d'état au numérique a évidemment
énormément travaillé sur ce sur ce sujet
là pour vous répondre
une phase de pré fiq de ce que j'ai vu
du dossier mais je les ai vus dans son
entièreté
il ya une phase de préfiguration au
cours de laquelle il fallait agir vite
identifié un acteur capable de
développer une plateforme de gestion de
sécurisation des données factuelles mans
est juridiquement et le président de
lens il a d'ailleurs confortées
microsoft est considéré dans son entité
gestionnaire des données de santé
françaises comme une entité européenne
même si c'est le groupe est américain
maintenant oui il y aura un appel
d'offres puisque dans le fonctionnement
dans le fonctionnement au quotidien et
dans la durée nous serons amenés à faire
un appel d'offres et j'espère et je vous
connais vous identifier un grand acteur
européen voire pourquoi pas français
pour assurer dans la durée la gestion le
stockage et le partage de ces données
ma question monsieur le ministre est on
ne peut plus d'actualité puisque
aujourd'hui nous apprenons que
considérant les les ingérences des
services de renseignement américains sur
les données des européens contient
qu'ils étaient trop grands la cour de
justice de l'union européenne vient à
valider l'accord de transfert des
données dix prévenus si schild et
microsoft obéit bien à cette législation
américaine ne nous trompons pas ce que
je pense qu'il nous faut un cadre
désormais l'initiative qui impose la
datar et zidane si les données en europe
traité en europe il faut travailler à ce
sujet et je propose aussi monsieur le
premier ministre qui a annoncé un plan
de relance de 40 milliards d'euros et
bacon investissent massivement dans ces
filières pour garantir de souveraineté
industrielle et numérique
merci madame la présidente
la parole est ' notre collègue stéphane
pieds noirs pour le groupe les
républicains n'avaient la parole merci
monsieur le président madame la ministre
entre 90,1 et 98 4%
il ne s'agit pas d du taux d'approbation
des dernières orientations du politburo
ni du résultat d'un vote à main levée
dans un parti politique en mal de
démocratie interne nos ces chiffres
traduisent le niveau de réussite au
baccalauréat session 2020 de la filière
technologique à la filière générale pour
atteindre globalement un record national
à 95 7 % qu'il sera bien difficile à
battre en tout cas tant que nous
consentirons à rester sous la barre des
100% après avoir assuré la continuité
pédagogique les professeurs ont donc été
particulièrement attentif à la demande
de leur ministre de tutelle d'être
bienveillant lors de l'examen des
dossiers du des candidats au
baccalauréat alors certes on peut se
réjouir de cette indulgence des jurés
délibération mais le risque de
dévaluation du diplôme n'est quand même
pas très loin et puis il y a un autre
effet collatéral
avec ce taux de réussite exceptionnel
conjuguée à une classe d'âge assez
nombreuses en réalité cela va venir
augmenter mécaniquement le nombre
d'étudiants sur les rangs de l'anp dans
les rangs de l'enseignement supérieur
d'environ 35 mille étudiants
supplémentaires ce qui représente quand
même l'équivalent de l'université de
nantes
à cela vont venir s'ajouter des jeunes
qui vont choisir de repousser de
continuer leur formation pour repousser
leur rentrée sera marché du travail qui
est sinistrée nos universités qui sont
déjà en souffrance s'inquiète de la
rentrée qui arrivent et qui s'annonce
comme finalement la quadrature du cercle
accueillir davantage de monde dans des
locaux qui sont exigus construite il ya
plus de 40 ans appliquer des règles
sanitaires de distanciation sociale pour
éviter la propagation du virus proposer
des modules de remédiation pour tenir
compte d'une année scolaire qui a été
très largement tronquée madame la
ministre que proposez-vous aux
établissements d'enseignement secondaire
pour faire face à ces lourdes
contraintes
pour vous répondre la parole est à
madame la ministre de l'enseignement
supérieur de la recherche d'innovation
david hâle vous avez la parole merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur piano tout d'abord
permettez moi de féliciter l'ensemble
des lycéens qui cette année ont obtenu
leur baccalauréat après une année aussi
perturbé après une année scolaire aussi
difficile où l'immense majorité d'entre
eux ont eu néanmoins le courage de
continuer à suivre des enseignements
dans des conditions de confinement
extrêmement difficile à vivre pour
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens et plus
particulièrement pour les jeunes et
permettez moi aussi de saluer le travail
de tous les enseignants qui les ont
accompagnés alors oui vous avez raison
nous allons avoir cette année l'ensemble
de ces jeunes à accompagner ceux qui
vont entrer dans l'enseignement
supérieur
ceux qui vont désiré poursuivre leurs
études et puis ceux qui vont sortir sur
le marché du travail et nous savons que
ce sera compliqué c'est pourquoi le
président de la république le 14 juillet
le premier ministre hier dans son
discours de politique générale ont
indiqué que notre priorité ce serait de
trouver une solution pour chacun de ces
jeunes vous savez parce que vous avez
participé tous ici à la construction de
la loi orientation et réussite des
étudiants nous avons des outils pour le
faire c'est plus d'un milliard d'euros
investis dans le plan étudiants c'est
des outils qui ont été créées par les
établissements pour accompagner les
jeunes et les prendre tels qu'ils sont
de manière à les amener vers la réussite
la plateforme parcours sup a fait la
preuve de sa robustesse
tous les lycéens vous le savez avant les
résultats du baccalauréat ils sont
inscrits à la veille de la fermeture de
la
la première phase nous avons 88 % des
lycéens qui ont reçu une proposition
nous sommes en train d'en accompagner
individuellement plus de 9000 nous avons
travaillé à des créations de plusieurs
milliers de places de bts de filières
courtes de formations
professionnalisantes plus de 1000
nouvelles formations en apprentissage
parce que nous devons aussi accompagner
les jeunes qui ont besoin de
l'apprentissage pour étudier nous
trouverons une solution pour chacun de
nos jeunes c'est un engagement qui a été
pris au plus haut niveau je vous
remercie
quelques secondes monsieur pieds-noirs
la ministre je ne doute pas de votre
volonté de celle du président la
république de régler ce problème
néanmoins on a un problème structurel
vaut les services du ministère ont
programmé jusqu'en 2028 une augmentation
conséquente des effectifs dans
l'enseignement supérieur
on a une rentrée qui est singulière avec
cette crise sanitaire je ne suis pas sûr
que le nombre de places que vous avez
cités en bts en apprentissage suffira à
accueillir ses trente cinq mille
étudiants supplémentaires
on nous regarderons ça avec attention
évidemment la parole et à notre collègue
jean jacques lozach
pour le groupe socialiste et républicain
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre de la
cohésion des territoires et des
relations avec les collectivités
territoriales
ces derniers mois des différentes
initiatives et solidarité conduite par
les collectivités des différents
échelons territoriaux ont manifestement
contribué à assurer la protection
sanitaire des français la continuité des
services publics et à soutenir les
tissus économiques locaux le
gouvernement a d'ailleurs fait reposer
sa stratégie de gestion de la crise et
de déconfinement en grande partie sur
les collectivités les élus locaux ont
fait preuve de réactivité d'adaptabilité
compensant certaines rigidités et
imprécisions de l'état et des montants à
nouveau l'importance des acteurs de
proximité
la dégradation la situation financière
des collectivités résultat de la baisse
importante de leurs recettes évaluées à
7,5 milliards d'euros en 2020 et à plus
de 10 pour 2021
conjuguée à l'augmentation simultanée
des dépenses sociales
les frangines les fragilise grandement
en plus de réduire leur capacité de
mobilisation
cette chute des ressources à terre aussi
leur agilité alors qu'elles seront
amenés à jouer un rôle central dans le
plan de développement économique
annoncée je pense notamment à la relance
de l'investissement et de la commande
publique pour cette année et pour 2021
le troisième projet de loi de finances
rectificatif actuellement en discussions
portent des mesures à hauteur de 4,5
milliards d'euros à l'endroit des
collectivités avec essentiellement des
avances remboursables sait s'ils
viennent partiellement amortir le choc
financier mais c'est insuffisant à la
maintenir leurs capacités
d'investissement dans des secteurs
décisifs tels que les mobilités le
déploiement du numérique la relance
verte ou la relocalisation d'activités
stratégiques seront elles en capacité de
poursuivre leurs actions en faveur de
l'égalité territoriale et de la justice
sociale et de permettre aux territoires
ruraux de relever le défi démographique
par une politique d'accueil
plus globalement n'est-il pas temps
madame des ministres de libérer les
collectivités de tout un ensemble de
contraintes budgétaires réduisant leur
autonomie fiscale et d'amorcer un virage
ouvertement décentralisateur enfin
pourriez vous nous préciser dans quelle
mesure l'agencé nationale de la cohésion
des territoires sera t-elle mobilisés
afin d'accompagner temps les porteurs de
grands programmes
les projets émergent locaux dans le
nombre devrait se multiplier en vue
d'impulser la relance pour vous répondre
la parole est à madame la ministre de la
cohésion des territoires des relations
et les collectivités territoriales
madame jacqueline gourault vous avez la
parole sénateur lozach votre question
est assez vaste mais je vais essayer de
prendre des exemples concrets
vous avez démontré le rôle des
collectivités territoriales et bien sûr
le fait qu'elle soit engagée dans la
relance
naturellement le premier ministre l'a
dit hier à l'assemblée et ce matin ici
même au sénat il y aura un plan de
relance annoncées à l'automne
enfin ne pas l'automne à la fin de l'été
d'environ 100 milliards d'euros est
naturellement ce plan concerne aussi les
collectivités territoriales nous avons
plusieurs outils et vous venez de le
rappeler je vais commencer par rappeler
l'outil qui s'appelle territoire
d'industrie c'est un outil qui est prêt
il y à 148 territoire d'industrie en
france on a fait remonter plusieurs
centaines de projets qui sont prêts à
démarrer et vous savez que territoire
d'industrie est animé par les régions
les intercommunalités et les chefs
d'entreprise c'est quelque chose de
concret avec des projets qui sont là
prêts à être lancés
deuxième chose vous savez que nous
sommes aussi dans l'année de
reconduction des contrats de plan état
région que nous négocions bien sûr avec
les régions actuellement et avec les
premiers ministres nous avons reçu ou
c'est plutôt le premier ministre qui a
reçu les régions cette semaine et nous
avons parlé de ce plan de relance et de
ce per lead et bien sûr c'est de faire
un plan commun de relance immédiats et à
long terme pour les collectivités
territoriales j'ajoute que dans les cpe
r il y a un volet territorial qui
concerne tous les niveaux de
collectivités territoriales les communes
les intercommunalités les départements
et donc on va décliner que ce soit la
transition écologique que ce soit la fin
relation des jeunes que ce soit l'outil
industriel à développer ou la
réindustrialisation des territoires vont
être à l'intérieur de ces contrats et
c'est fondamental donc toutes les
collectivités seront associés j'ajoute
pour terminer que selanne et aussi de
renouvellement des fonds européens
ce qu'on appelle les fonds de cohésion
et évidemment ils vont être un apport
d'érable au plan de relance en plus des
35 milliards exceptionnelle de la
négocier par la france avec l'allemagne
au niveau européen c'est ma journée de
tendresse madame la ministre dont la
parole à notre collègue jean françois
husson pour le groupe l'est républicain
ma question s'adresse à madame les
ministres de la transition écologique
dans la valse des milliards qui finit
par donner le vertige et nouveaux
crédits consacrés à l'écologie son
patient d'une semaine de 15 à 20
milliards d'euros
importants en valeur absolue certes cet
engagement annoncé ne représente
pourtant qu'à peine 4 % des plus de 500
milliards de crédits débloqués par le
gouvernement
malgré ces sommes nous avons du mal à
comprendre à la fois la cohérence et la
stratégie de votre politique
environnementale et écologique
alors que vous êtes là quatrième
ministre de l'écologie en à peine trois
ans au conseil pour le climat
commencions citoyenne conseil de défense
écologique autant de paravent pour mieux
masquer vos incertitudes et tenir à
distance et proposition du parlement
alors à ce stade madame la ministre que
vous nous indiquez votre stratégie et le
plan d'action concret par lequel voulait
permettre à la france de redonner corps
a une ambition écologique
la parole est à madame la ministre la
transition écologique pour l'impôt payé
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur jean françois husson
alors vous avez certainement une vue un
peu sélective parce que d'abord dire
qu'il n'y a rien eu de fait jusque
maintenant c'est quand même oublié ce
qui est passé par le parlement et en
tant qu ancien parlementaire je peux
vous dire que la loi mobilité où on
abandonne les grands plans on revient
sur les mobilités du quotidien ça a été
une grande avancée nous avons eu la loi
sur l'économie circulaire nous avons une
loi énergie climat
l'arrêt des centrales à charbon et
aidera j'en passe donc dire qu'il n'y a
rien eu de fait me paraît un petit peu
exagéré dire que vous ne voyez que du
flou dans ce que nous proposons non je
crois qu'au contraire nous avons une
opportunité qui est dû à cette terrible
crise que nous vivons mais qui nous
permet l'ajustement de pouvoir impulser
de nouvelles orientations et une
accélération surtout de cette politique
l'accélération de cette politique elle
va se traduire en ce qui concerne la
transition écologique très visiblement
par deux plans de relance ou là nous
allons avoir sur 100 milliards d'euros
+30 % donc je crois que même les
chiffres vont vous pouvez les faire
remonter parce que nous au fur et à
mesure nous regardons ce que nous
pouvons mettre dans ce dans ce plan de
relance de 30 % qui vont être consacrés
la transition écologique dans des enjeux
essentiels qui sont les enjeux de baisse
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre
sur les secteurs concernés les
transports j'en ai déjà parlé tout à
l'heure la rénovation thermique des
logements l'agriculture l'industrie
bref tout va être mis en place pour
lancer des dynamiques pour qu'eux aussi
des acteurs puissent se former on a
besoin d'une formation sur les
territoires pour qu' on en utilise les
emplois locaux et qu'on arrête d'avoir
des emplois qui viennent de l'extérieur
ou qu'on en voit dans des usines à
l'autre bout du monde
voilà ce que nous allons faire et puis
nous avons nous allons avoir au
parlement ce projet de loi qui va
reprendre les propositions d'ordre
législatif de la convention citoyenne
pour les climats pour lequel encore une
fois avec marc fesneau nous avons décidé
de mettre en place des groupes de
travail pour associer tout le monde à
l'élaboration afin que la parole des
parlementaires soient prises en compte
et j'y serai très vigilante vous
d'imaginer bien sûr
madame la ministre en mode simple je
vous dirais que le risque
le disque pardon est rayé et les
français n'ont plus confiance
le premier ministre l'a lui-même
exprimant expressément dit pour
développer la filière hydrogène vous
alignez 100 millions d'euros quand
l'allemagne mais plus de 10 milliards
sur la table
vous prenez une économie décarbonée sans
rendre d'arbitrage claire en matière
d'énergies renouvelables et vous
affaiblissez notre filière nucléaire
acteur majeur de décarbonation vous
parlez de réduire les émissions
polluantes et depuis trois ans rien n'a
été fait pour la qualité de l'air
pour preuve la condamnation par le
conseil d'état à 10 millions d'euros
d'amendé par semestre
les enjeux écologiques sont étroitement
liées aux enjeux sanitaires et de santé
publique comme la crise actuelle nous le
rappelle alors vite au-delà de la
vélorution magique poste qu'ovide
abandonné la verticalité de vaud
politique est faite de l'environnement
le socle d'un nouveau pacte de confiance
reposant sur trois piliers économique
écologique et social
on en a besoin il nous faut sortir
définitivement de cette écologie
punitive qui a donné lieu à la crise des
gilet jaune fait enfin le choix d'une
économie d'une écologie positive au
service de la france
merci la parole est à notre collègue
loïc hervé pour le groupe de l'union
centriste
merci monsieur le président à ma
question s'adresse à madame jacqueline
gourault ministre de la cohésion des
territoires et des relations avec les
collectivités territoriales
hier dans le discours de politique
générale de monsieur le premier ministre
qui nous a été lue ici on retrouve le
mot territoire à 25 reprises dans les
mêmes phrases on parle de confiance on
parle d'intelligence
on parle de proximité vous nous imaginez
bien combien ici au sénat nous sommes
sensibles à tout cela notre pays a pu
compter sur les collectivités
territoriales pour gérer et assumer les
charges de la crise sanitaire
notre pays aura besoin de mains de ces
mêmes collectivités pour panser les
plaies et relancer la machine économique
les conseils départementaux avec leurs
compétences sociales ont été inventifs
et ont essayé d'apporter une aide
adaptée aux besoins les plus criants
ainsi en est il de la haute savoie où
les élus ont voté un dispositif d aide à
1600 entrepreneurs qui ont été très
sévèrement touchés par la crise à
l'instant où je vous parle le virement
de ces aides bien qu'ils ont été
considérés comme conformes au droit par
le contrôle de légalité du préfet n'est
toujours pas effectif cette situation
est pénalisante et suscite la plus
grande des inquiétudes parmi les élus
madame la ministre sans attendre que la
différenciation ne devienne un principe
organico constitutionnel comment
entendez vous permettre aux
collectivités d'être de vrais acteurs de
l'après crise pour vous répondre
la parole est à madame jacqueline
gourault mais liste de la cohésion des
territoires des relations avec le
parlement cher loïc hervé merci pour
votre question je voudrais rapport
rappeler quelques éléments de contexte
vous le savez le département est
compétent comme vous l'avez rappelé vous
même sur la politique sociale et d'autre
chose mais la politique sociale est le
substrat jeudi fondamental de l'action
des départements et vous connaissez mon
attachement à ce que l'on respecte la
loi dans la répartition des compétences
et vous avez rappelé que le conseil
départemental de haute savoie
à adopter un règlement dead en faveur
des travailleurs non salariés
nommé ne bénéficions pas du chômage
partiel
la délibération du département a été
transmise aux préfets ainsi qu'au
directeur départemental des finances
publiques pour qu'ils puissent en
examiner la légalité vous savez que le
contrôle de légalité
c'est aussi un service à rendre aux
collectivités et ce contrôle s'est
effectuée en lien avec le président du
conseil départemental qui a eu
l'occasion de fournir toutes les
informations utiles à l'examen à l'uci à
l'issue de cette instruction dont je
rappelle qu'elle est parfaitement normal
dans un état de droit il apparaît que le
règlement voté par le département
institut bien une aide de nature sociale
destinée à des personnes physiques est
conditionnée à des plafonds de
ressources
donc comme vous me posez la question
comme lé député de haute-savoie m'ont
posé également la question je vous dis
que aujourd'hui eh bien il n'ya pas
d'observations particulières et je peux
associé à mon propos olivier du soft que
je ne vois plus telle est la ba ba oui
olivier du sorte on regarde il n'y a
aucun problème au regard du de la
légalité de cette délibération
il ne s'agit pas donc de d'une souplesse
particulière mais tout simplement de la
stricte application des textes et voilà
donc je crois que je vous ai rassurés
monsieur le chien avait un mot pour
remercier la ministre de cette bonne
nouvelle pour pas seulement pour le
conseil départemental de l'aude sa voix
et ses élus mais surtout pour ces
travailleurs non salariés qui sont en
général des personnes qui ont de toutes
petites entreprises et qui se trouvait
bien démunis avec la situation
économique est la nôtre et puis vous
dire que avec l'avènement de la loi 3d
dans l'est dans les mois qui viennent
combien est ici au sénat on est attentif
à pouvoir parfois déverrouiller est
donnée de nous de nouvelles libertés aux
collectivités territoriales et donner
une capacité à répondre aux nouveaux
défis de
de la période qui est devant nous je
remercie la parole est maintenant notre
collègue annie del mon corps police pour
le groupe l'est républicain avait la
parole
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre les
solidarités de la santé monsieur le
ministre à l'occasion de la
traditionnelle interview du 14 juillet
le président de la république a affirmé
avec assurance
on a réussi à endiguer le virus et a
retrouvé une presque une vie normale en
tant que médecin ayant exercé pendant la
crise et en tant que parlementaire
informé des remontées nationale j'ai
l'impression que nous ne vivons pas la
même réalité
depuis plusieurs semaines déjà les
indicateurs nous alertent le virus est
toujours là et dans certains
départements il progresse à nouveau et
de façon très inquiétante
monsieur le ministre nous ne sommes pas
sortis d'affaires loin de là et le
chemin vers la vie presque normale
risque d'être beaucoup plus long au vu
des mesures que vous prenez trop
tardivement ou que vous ne prenez pas
partout ailleurs en europe et au canada
le port du masque dans les lieux publics
a déjà été rendue obligatoire et ce sans
préalablement annoncé une période
incompréhensible de 15 jours notre
président de groupe bruno retailleau à
demander son application immédiate ce
matin et vous avez finalement entendu
raison mais quelle perte de temps
de plus des dépistages systématiques et
massif doivent être organisées
régulièrement car c'est bien le moyen le
plus efficace pour briser les chaînes de
contamination on a le sentiment que vous
n'avez rien appris nous sommes dans la
même situation qu'au mois de février
avec un virus qui reprend sa progression
monsieur le ministre face à l'urgence le
gouvernement doit entendre l'inquiétude
des professionnels de santé et adopter
une stratégie phase offensive
face à cette épidémie qui ne sera
éradiquée que par des mesures drastiques
ma question est donc la suivante
qu'attendez vous pour cesser d'être
spectateur il faut agir nous perdons du
temps pour vous répondre la parole
au ministre des solidarités de la santé
monsieur virant merci madame la
sénatrice pour cette question qui comme
on le dit avait-il puisque vous et moi
ça médecin a été posée avec tact et
mesure mais c'est moi vous féliciter
sincèrement d'avoir repris la blouse
pendant la période épidémique je pense
que les français vous en son gré on peut
s'entendre madame la sénatrice plusieurs
constats d'abord sur le port du masque
qui sera rendue obligatoire dans les
milieux fermés vous posez la question du
1er août
vous le savez nous faisons confiance à
l'arrêt ce prix de responsabilité des
français
nous expliquons les choses nous les
accompagnons et porter une obligation du
jour au lendemain est quelque chose qui
est jugée un peu brutal d'autant qu'il
ya également un travail à faire avec les
entreprises avec le milieu culturel avec
les milieux sportifs pour que chacun
puisse préparer cette obligation du port
du masque néanmoins à madame la
sénatrice vous avez été entendu avant
même d'avoir prononcé votre question
puisque le premier ministre s'est engagé
ce matin à ce que l'obligation soit
actée dès la semaine prochaine je peux
même vous dire qu en l'état nous ne nous
dirigeons vraisemblablement vers une
obligation à compter de lundi ou mardi
en tout cas au tout début de la semaine
prochaine et sans attendre
j'appelle les français à porter un
masque comme par exemple dans cet
hémicycle sénatoriales madame la
sénatrice
lorsque vous êtes en milieu fermé et
qu'en plus vous êtes un certain nombre
ici rassemblez vous poser la question
enfin vous ne vous posez pas la question
vous considérez que nous sommes inactifs
madame la sénatrice je pourrais vous
faire constater qu'un certain nombre de
pays ont été conduits à 1 re confinement
parfois généralisée territoriales y
compris des pays dont j'ai souvent
entendu parler dans cet hémicycle
pendant la période épidémique comme
étant des modèles ce qui n'a pas été le
cas en france pour une simple raison
madame la sénatrice c'est que depuis 12
semaines pendant 12 semaines les
indicateurs se sont améliorées
continuellement en revanche vous avez
raison de souligner qu'il ya des
indicateurs qui doivent nous alerter
nous inquiéter je lui ai dit tout à
l'heure à l'assemblée nationale
notamment dans certains hôpitaux
parisiens
en mayenne et c'est pourquoi nous
démultiplions les capacités de test de
contact traces hymne à la sénatrice j'ai
débattu ici des heures durant pour
expliquer pourquoi il était fondamental
de ne pas désarmer juridiquement
l'exécutif le gouvernement dans sa
capacité à agir et à prendre les bonnes
décisions au bon moment
alors que nous sortions de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire je vous propose de
regarder les comptes rendus
madame la sénatrice des débats vous
verrez que nous contre lui qui était le
ce n'était certainement pas moi ici qui
prônait le moins d'activités au
contraire quelques secondes
oui mettre en place et mesure prend du
temps mais vous auriez dû les prendre
avant et ne pas vous y résoudre dernier
moment soyez vigilants monsieur le
ministre car demain lorsque la
population sacrifier les familles vous
demanderont des comptes
vous ne pourrez plus dire nous ne
savions pas merci la parole et que notre
collègue julien bargeton pour le groupe
de la république en marche
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à mana ministre du
travail de l'emploi et de l'insertion
cela a été annoncé par le président de
la république comme par le premier
ministre la jeunesse est la priorité des
mois qui viennent car il ne faut pas
ajouter à la crise sanitaire
la difficulté des jeunes à accéder à
l'emploi les difficultés d'insertion
professionnelle des jeunes ne date pas
de mars dernier et beaucoup avaient déjà
été entrepris par votre prédécesseur is
notamment le plan d'investissement dans
les compétences
cette épreuve exceptionnelle appel des
décisions exceptionnelles en particulier
pour les quelques 700 mille jeunes qui
vont rentrer sur le marché du travail
plus que jamais notre jeunesse dans sa
diversité a besoin de perspectives
d'avenir le meilleur des plans de
relance c'est celui qui ne laisse aucun
jeune en plan c'est pourquoi des mesures
ambitieuses sont très attendus nous
examinons demain le troisième budget
d'urgence et nous votons notamment une
prime à l'embauché exceptionnelle pour
le recrutement des apprentis jusqu'à
8000 euros ou bien une prime de 200
euros pour les jeunes les plus précaires
primal embauche pour inciter les
entreprises à recruter des jeunes
augmentation des parcours et des
contrats d'insertion renforcement du
service civique tous la bonne
application de ces mesures dans les
territoires sera la garante du succès de
cette démarche
madame la ministre dès lors et sans
préjuger de
que sera la concertation avec les
partenaires sociaux quels sont les
objectifs quels sont les axes quels sont
le calendrier de mise en route des
mesures de mobilisation pour les jeunes
dans l'emploi
merci beaucoup pour vous répondre la
parole et à madame la ministre du
travail de l'emploi et de l'insertion
madame elisabeth bord neuf la parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur julien bargeton vous avez
raison il y a urgence pour notre
jeunesse nous avons demandé des
sacrifices importants à nos jeunes
pendant le confinement pour protéger nos
aînés et nous devons aujourd'hui le
renvoyer l'ascenseur notre objectif est
donc clair aucun jeunes sans solution
grâce à des réponses adaptées à chaque
situation
alors pour les jeunes qui sont les plus
proches de l'emploi nous allons
favoriser les embauches avec une
compensation de charge de 4000 euros par
an pour un cdi ou un cdd suffisamment
long pour les jeunes qui veulent
s'engager sur un contrat d'apprentissage
ou un contrat de professionnalisation on
doit veiller à ce qu'ils puissent
trouver une entreprise d'accueil c'est
ce que nous faisons avec la prime de
5000 euros pour les moins de 18 ans 8000
euros pour les autres et donc nous
allons continuer à mettre le paquet sur
l'apprentissage
nous allons également créer cent mille
service suivi civique supplémentaires
pour permettre à des jeunes de s'engager
dans des missions utiles à la société
en attendant une conjoncture meilleure
et puis pour les jeunes les plus en
difficulté nous allons créer 300 milles
parcourus ou contrats d'insertion
supplémentaires nous allons nous appuyer
sur les dispositifs qui existent et avec
les acteurs locaux
nous devons faire de ces parcours et de
ses contrats d'insertion t véritable
tremplin vers des emplois durables
donc c'est vraiment une réponse globale
et ce plan fera l'objet d'une
concertation dès demain avec des
partenaires sociaux conformément à la
méthode qui vous a été exposée ce matin
par monsieur le premier ministre vous
aurez l'occasion de soutenir ces mesures
dans le cadre de l'examen de la loi de
finances
qu'ils encourent et je pense mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs que notre
jeunesse ne peut pas attendre
nous allons préparer avec les
partenaires sociaux avec les territoires
avec les parlementaires
une réponse à la hauteur des enjeux je
bargeton la parole et à notre collègue
pierre qui perce pour le groupe irait du
new girl
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre en août 2016
le gouvernement est vrai pour
l'interdiction à compter du 1er
septembre 2018 de certains produits
sanitaire beh fongicides et
d'insecticides dont d'ailleurs la
non-dangerosité sur l'homme a été
prouvée le président de la république
avait déclaré à l'époque
il n'y aura pas d'arrêt s'il n'y a pas
de produit de substitution
d'ici à trois ans or il est prouvé
aujourd'hui que les produits proposés
par l'homme cesse sont totalement
inefficaces et contreproductif
monsieur le ministre vous avez pu le
vérifier je vous en remercie mardi
dernier que fait le gouvernement
il est en train de ruiner les cultures
françaises en particulier celle de la
betterave atteindre par une invasion de
pucerons leur transmettant là je lis
virale qui entraîne une perte colossale
de 30 à 70%
c'est tout un pan de notre économie
dynamique agricole qui est atteinte
cette année c'est inadmissible alors que
vous étiez prévenus depuis des mois de
l'inefficacité des produits des risques
économiques et sociaux et de fermetures
d'usinés si les bonnes dispositions ne
sont pas prises d'ici à quinze jours
il n'y aura plus d'alcool plus de gel
hydroalcoolique plus de sucre plus
d'alimentation du bétail les français
alors consommeront des produits importés
est fabriqué avec nos produits interdits
est ce ainsi que l'on dit la mise une
filière qui marche
voulez-vous l'anéantir quel est votre
solution
on vous répond de la parole et à
monsieur le ministre de l'agriculture et
de l'alimentation
le président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur pierre
cuite merci
plusieurs points d'abord je partage
votre inquiétude et vous le savez cette
inquiétude qui est lié à cette jaunisse
de la betterave qui aujourd'hui au
moment où je vous parle provoque parfois
30 à 40 % de rendement de moins sur les
champs de betteraves et la faute à ceux
pucerons verts qui vient infectés du
syndrome de la jaunisse ces betteraves
qui par manque de photosynthèse ne peut
plus faire ça racines tubéreuses est
rempli de sucre cette inquiétude elle
est d'autant plus forte que ce n'est pas
que les champs de betteraves ce n'est
pas que les betteraviers c'est
l'ensemble de la filière parce que quand
dans un territoire
vous avez des chutes de rendement dans
vos champs de betteraves
c'est la sucrerie d'à côté qui est mise
en cause et donc l'inquiétude
soyez en sûr mais je savais que vous le
savez je la partage pleinement que fait
le gouvernement
là où je vous rejoindrai pas le
gouvernement n'est pas en train de
mettre à mal la filière le gouvernement
il cherche à trouver une solution
jusqu'à présent le gouvernement il
applique comme tout le monde ici une loi
qui date de 2016 le gouvernement le 14
juillet j y étais pour rendre hommage à
toutes celles et ceux dans le monde
agricole qui ont tenu pendant la période
du coc vide et j'ai voulu me rendre non
seulement ce jour du 14 juillet mais
être avec vous en seine-et-marne pour
être sur un champ de betteraves et
discuter avec l'ensemble des personnes
représentatives de la filière le 15
juillet c'est à dire hier il y avait une
réunion à mon ministère avec l'ensemble
de ces professionnels et ma
détermination
elle est aussi forte que mon inquiétude
elle est totale pour trouver une
solution
est ce qu'il faut faire des dérogations
de en question c'est très compliqué on
en a parlé c'est la loi aujourd'hui est
ce qu'il faut trouver des alternatives
je partage avec vous ça fait quatre ans
qu'on sait qu'il y a cette difficulté
l'alternative n'est toujours pas là
alors il ya des produits phyto qui sont
appliquées ici ou là mais il nous faut
accélérer pour trouver cette alternative
il faut investir pour trouver cette
alternative et puis se pose aussi cette
question de la compensation
mais ces trois alternatives vous les
connaissez comme moi monsieur le
sénateur je prends un engagement devant
vous c'est de tout faire tout faire tout
faire pour trouver la solution sans
aucune démagogie et avec beaucoup
d'énergie
récupère ce le temps nous presse et
pourtant le président de la république
lors de son allocution a réaffirmé qu'il
fallait réapprendre à produire ce dont
on a besoin
vous même monsieur le premier ministre
avant-hier non hier plutôt vous
affirmiez que nous sommes trop
dépendants de nos partenaires extérieurs
je prends acte de vos propos et en même
temps de vos contradictions aussi je le
dis avec force
j'accuse aujourd'hui le gouvernement de
la destruction de la filière betterave
j'accuse le gouvernement de la
destruction de la filière alcool et de
la fragilisation de nos productions
d'énergie et d'aliments du bétail
une attitude semblable est
incompréhensible pour notre société et
le monde agricole déjà au bord du
gouffre faites vite monsieur le premier
ministre
une dernière question mais aussi
dernière prise de parole de notre
collègue yves daudigny pour le groupe
socialiste et républicain pourrait
saluer son travail ici au cedar comme
secrétaire du sida mais aussi avec jean
pierre decool monsieur le premier
ministre monsieur le ministre des
solidarités de la santé un rapport en
2018 sur la pénurie de médicaments et
vaccins qui était une prescience par
rapport à ce que nous avons vécu je lui
cède la parole il représente le groupe
socialiste et républicain
merci monsieur le président pour vos
paroles
c'est encore l'occasion à cette
prochaine de débattre dans le sur le
sujet de la dette sociale
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre des solidarités et de la santé
de grave la situation de la psychiatrie
est passé à 4 as trophique titre une
récente tribune qui dénonce la pression
financière à l'exclusion de toute autre
vision maintenue sur ce secteur
dans le contexte présent après
suppression des 2/3 de lyon psychiatrie
insuffisance d accueil alternatifs et
des équipes mobiles financement sans
lien avec les besoins locaux accès
difficile au centre médico psychologique
20% des postes du secteur public non
pourvus pédopsychiatrie sinistrés
disparités territoriales extrême dans ce
contexte donc montrent la vague
psychiatriques liés aux qu'ovide 19 et
qui pourraient déferler à la rentrée sur
un système à bout de souffle la préco
vide sera psychiatrique affirme la
professeure leboyer pendant le
confinement
les pertes de suivi les ruptures de
traitement ont concerné 10 % des malades
faute de moyens humains suffisants ont
été mises en oeuvre
les privations de liberté un justifiée
médicalement est illégal dans des
conditions indignes pour les malades à
guînes hazan contrôleur général attire
l'attention sur la question des droits
des patients sur l'enfermement de plus
en plus important des malades mentaux
s'interroge sur les nouvelles règles des
hospitalisations sans consentement sur
l'utilisation abusive de l' isolement et
de la contention
monsieur le ministre avez vous la
volonté politique de donner dans notre
pays à la psychiatrie à la santé mentale
toute leur place en qualité et en
réponse aux besoins de la population
pour vous répondre la parole est aux
ministres de solidarité de la santé
monsieur le sénateur yves daudigny
puisqu'il me revient d'avoir l'immense
honneur d'être le dernier à vous
répondre dans cette noble assemblée
laissez moi vous dire à mon tour que
vous avez laissé un travail considérable
notamment en matière de politique de
santé nous avons eu l'occasion d'en
discuter
bien avant et sous une mandature
précédente et je crois que vous
manquerez au sénat est en tout cas à
titre personnel vous manquerez dans
cette assemblée sénatoriales vous posez
une question tout à fait juste sur le
risque de vagues et psychiatriques
j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de répondre à
cette question
le traumatisme psychologique pour
l'ensemble de la population liés au
confinement lié à la peur d'être malade
liés à la perte d'êtres chers qu on ne
pouvait même pas enterrés en famille ce
traumatisme est important il est même
sans doute considérable
il ya un travail de résilience
collective que nous devons entamer avec
les français au plus vite
pendant toute la période de la crise
épidémique dé soutien psychologique ont
été mis en place par des associations
par des professionnels du système du
secteur sanitaire et médico sociales y
compris d'ailleurs pour soutenir les
soignants eux mêmes qui ont été soumis à
un stress épouvantable
mois après mois semaine après semaine
dans notre pays le secteur de la
psychiatrie monsieur le sénateur vous
souligner qu'il ait eu des abus
identifiés dans un rapport de la laddh
madame hazan je ne voudrais pas que vous
gardez cette image de la gestion de la
crise qu vide par le mythe de la
psychiatrie parce que le milieu de la
psychiatrie a fait face avec une dignité
et un professionnalisme à toute épreuve
semaine après semaine parce que c'est
très compliqué quand vous avez des
patients qui sont en situation de délire
à qui vous devez expliquer qu'il ya un
virus quelque chose d'une agression
invisible lorsque vous devez parfois
isolés des personnes en plein de
confinement tout cela est extrêmement
difficile et pourtant le secteur de la
psychiatrie a tenu et le secteur de la
psychiatrie je le shérif tout comme vous
le shérif c'est monsieur le sénateur
c'est pourquoi parmi les quinze mille
postes parmi les quinze mille postes qui
ont été annoncé la création par le
premier ministre dans le cadre du ségur
de la santé il y aura des postes dédiés
à la psychiatrie et je vous confirme ce
qui a été également dit l'année dernière
à savoir que quoi qu'il arrive
l'augmentation du budget des soins de
santé mentale ne pourra pas être
inférieure à l'augmentation générale du
budget de la santé ce qui sera une
rupture avec les années précédentes il
ya beaucoup à faire pour l'abc beaucoup
à faire pour la pédopsychiatrie
énormément à faire de façon générale
pour la santé mentale dans notre pays
croyait en ma détermination sur ce sujet
que daudigny monsieur le ministre merci
pour les propos qui me touche
particulièrement l'engagement et le
dévouement des soignants n'est pas mise
en doute
mais il y avait cap 6 4 et la santé
mentale deux enjeux un enjeu bien
évidemment de santé publique plus deux
millions de personnes concernées mais
aussi un enjeu qui est de réconcilier
avec le pays
les malades mentaux et les soignants en
psychiatrie ce qui serait à mon sens un
élément constitutif d'un humanisme
républicain je vous remercie
merci
merci monsieur le premier ministre et
dames et messieurs les ministres nos
prochaines questions d'actualité auront
lieu le mercredi 22 juillet à 15 heures
je vais maintenant levé la séance
notre prochaine séance aura lieu
vendredi 17 juillet à 11 heures pour la
discussion des articles du projet de loi
de finances rectificatif notre séance
est levée
[Musique]
voilà pour cette séance de questions
d'actualité
une séance de questions d'actualité 1
aura exceptionnelle 1 18 heures
aujourd'hui et qui a été marqué par
notamment un échange entre la nouvelle
sénatrice socialiste de la sarthe muriel
cabaret qui a interrogé le gouvernement
sur la nomination comme ministre de
l'intérieur de gérald darmanin
une nomination qui provoque le débat et
notamment la colère des féministes car
le ministre de l'intérieur est accusé de
viol alors il a été défendu par le
président de la république emmanuel
macron le 14 juillet au nom du principe
de la présomption d'innocence
le premier ministre jean castex lui a
rappelé quant à lui elle les principes
fondamentaux de l'état de droit se sont
lassés mots et pour la première fois on
a senti dans l'hémicycle jean castex
assez agacé écouter cet échange tout à
l'heure avec le président vous affichez
votre soutien sans faille au ministre de
l'intérieur
sans même attendre la fin de la
procédure judiciaire c'est une erreur
éthique politique d'une violence
symbolique
inouï que nous dit vous en réalité que
monsieur darmanin qui ne sont que la
victime mans au mépris des principes
d'équité du contradictoire et d'
équilibre entre les parties
monsieur darmanin n'a fait l'objet
d'aucune condamnation et à ce que je
sache
à chaque fois que l'autorité judiciaire
a eu à se prononcer dans cette affaire
elle a rendu des actes consacrant
l'innocence de monsieur darmanin c'est
donc en mon âme et conscience
madame
au delà au delà du respect des principes
fondamentaux de la république que j'ai
fait de proposition votre intervention
madame suppose donc que j'aurais biaiser
avec ma conscience et ça je ne vous
autorise pas à le dire
voilà pour ce temps fort de la séance de
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
des questions que nous allons débriefer
sur ce plateau avec loïc hervé bonsoir
soir vous êtes sénateur uc de la haute
savoie on vous a d'ailleurs entendu tout
à l'heure interroger le gouvernement on
va parler de cette question des
territoires mais d'abord votre réaction
sur cet échange
qu'est ce que vous avez pensé et bien de
la défense notamment du premier ministre
de la nomination du ministre de
l'intérieur on sait que c'est une
nomination qui fait débat et notamment
chez les féministes
vous savez je suis membre de la
délégation aux droits des femmes au
sénat et je suis pas susceptible d'être
mis en cause sur ce genre de questions
où je suis vraiment très impliqué très
investis je partage la colère du premier
ministre parce que je considère que
cette espèce de vie politique qui
consiste à se balancer des boules
puantes en permanence neuneu n'honore
pas le pays qui est le nôtre et bien sûr
qui s'il y avait une information
judiciaire une mise en examen et c'est
ce que je viens de vous dire ne
tiendrait plus mais pour l'instant ce
que vise ce qu'a dit le premier la
nation à la condamnation pas de mise en
examen
c'est simplement la réalité des faits et
de la procédure judiciaire qui n'existe
même pas ainsi on pouvait seulement se
s'abstraire un peu de cette situation
dans laquelle forcément on est dans le
commentaire à la bd le commentaire de la
boule puante je dis franchement je pense
que jean castex a fait pression jeudi
robert nomination gérald à toutes ces
questions qui sont des questions de
violence faite aux femmes voire
d'agressions sexuelles etc sont des
sujets qu'on ne peut plus prendre à la
légère qu'on ne doit pas prendre à la
légère
évidemment et pour autant peut-on jeté
en pâture systématiquement tout homme
politique
n'importe comment alors même que
visiblement les les enquêtes qui ont été
menées ont conduit à le blanchir et à
établir son innocence c'est la justice
dans notre pays qui détermine si on est
coupable ou si on est innocent et
personne d'autre c'est la justice qui
détermine si on est coupable ou innocent
va tout de suite
écoutez bien laurence rossignol qui est
au micro d'alexandre pusan du patient
quel va être du même avis que vous serez
vous alexandre et laurence rossignol
quel est votre avis sur cette défense du
premier ministre de la nomination de
gérald darmanin au ministère de
l'intérieur
malgré son enquête pour viol côté il ya
dans la manière dont le gouvernement
déroule son argumentaire des éléments de
langage sur la présomption d'innocence
un angle mort d'abord la présomption
d'innocence n'est nullement mis en cause
puisque monsieur darmanin du moins ses
avocats reconnaissent les faits les
fesses sont un échange de services
sexuelle une relation sexuelle contre
une promesse de passe-droits et le
premier ministre parle de présomption
d'innocence mais personne ne dit qu'il
est coupable
l'effet suffisent aujourd'hui pour qu'on
ait un point de vue sur ce qu'il a fait
que pense le premier ministre de cet
échange relations sexuelles contre passe
droit on ne sait toujours pas et je
pense que c'est une triple faute est une
faute à la fois politique éthique et
déontologique je rappelle que l'enquêté
toujours en cours sur les agissements de
monsieur darmanin comment les policiers
vont ils pouvoir enquêter sur leur
ministre de tutelle
et pourtant à chaque décision de justice
gérald darmanin étaient déclarés
innocents alors il ya eu des décisions
de justice
effectivement épiler eu la réouverture
de l'enquêté et pas simplement pour un
vice de procédure la réouverture de
l'enquêté elle est aussi dû au fait que
en réalité il n'ya pas eu d' enquête
il n'a pas eu de confrontation avec la
victime et la cour d'appel a considéré
que l' enquête était insuffisante pour
clore la sphère donc aujourd'hui il est
effectivement toujours présumé innocent
mais il est suspect et il est ministre
de l'intérieur ministre de tutelle des
enquêteurs on a donc là un véritable
poème d'anthologie qu indépendamment du
terrible message qui est envoyé aux
femmes qui elles vont déposer plainte
vont parle et on leur dit en fin de
compte c'est pas si grave ce qu'a fait
l'homme que vous
non c'est puisqu'il y en a il peut être
ministre de l'intérieur ait changé
relations sexuelles contre passe droit
donc pour vous gérald darmanin n'ai pas
jeté en pâture à cause de cette affaire
ah non il n'est pas jeté en pâture il
est aujourd'hui pas sa place là où il
est comme ministre de l'intérieur et de
la part du président macron qui l'a
nommé à cet endroit en connaissant tous
les faits il y à la fois comme une
espèce de d'indifférence sur les faits
il ya toujours aussi la mise en cause de
la plaignante comme dans toutes les
affaires de violences sexuelles on
cherche dans le passé de la plaignante
et puis il ya aussi cette faute
déontologique qui va rendre l'anc est
probablement plus compliquée pour les
enquêteurs pour terminer le premier
ministre jean castex a évoqué le fait
que gérald darmanin n'avait toujours pas
été mises en examen
est-ce que la mise en examen devient une
limite dans les propos du conflit
jusqu'à présent on a vu des ministres
qui étaient très rapidement gouvernement
alors qu'il n'était pas mis en examen je
pense à françois bayrou marielle de
sarnez sylvie goulard je pense même à
françois de rugy qui a quitté le
gouvernement pour avoir servi du homard
lorsqu'ils étaient présents de
l'assemblée il n'y avait même pas
d'infraction pénale en cause
et subitement il ya un changement de
jurisprudence du gouvernement et je suis
quand même étonné choqué que ce
changement de jurisprudence se fasse
justement sur une violence sexuelle
merci beaucoup laurence rossignol pour
votre réaction
autre réaction celle de thani mohamed
soilihi sénateurs la république en
marche toujours
et bien sûr la polémique suscitée par la
nomination de gérald darmanin comme
ministre de l'intérieur
thani mohamed soilihi le premier
ministre jean castex a défendu le
principe de la présomption d'innocence
concernant gérald darmanin qui fait
l'objet d'une enquête pour viol qu'est
ce que vous avez pensé de ce plaidoyer
énergique du premier ministre eh bien je
vais tout à fait dans son dans ce sens
il a rappelé un certain nombre de
principes qui régissent notre république
de celui ci le principe de la
présomption d'innocence
il ya aussi le principe selon lequel
seul un juge a compétence pour déclarer
un justiciable coupable ou innocent dans
cette affaire qui n'en est pas une
au moment où l'on parle parce que il ne
nous appartient pas en tant que
parlementaire de commenter une affaire
qui serait en cours mais dans cette
situation il y a déjà eu des décisions
qui ont innocenté
gérald hahnemann donc si à chaque fois
que quelqu'un se plaint il faudrait
remettre en cause le principe de la
présomption d'innocence
eh bien nous ne serions pas dans ce pays
des droits de l'homme que nous nous
aimons tant nous défendons tout
simplement c'est principes de notre de
notre pays le premier ministre a assuré
que gérald darmanin était au fond un
citoyen comme les autres
est ce que quand on est ministre de
l'intérieur on est un citoyen comme les
autres il est citoyen comme un autre qui
a été nommé à ce poste-là de deux
ministres de l'intérieur
bien évidemment il est avant tout un
citoyen qui par rapport aux principes
que je viens de de rappeler et bien ne
doit pas être traité ni moins bien ni
mieux que n'importe quel autre citoyen
et le fait qu'il soit ministre de
l'intérieur alors qu'il n'est pas mis en
examen dans cette affaire c'est ça que
le premier ministre a tenu à préciser il
n'est pas mis en examen
donc je ne vois pas pourquoi parce qu'il
est ministre de l'intérieur il faudrait
qu'ils soient traités différemment par
rapport à n'importe quel citoyen quel
autre citoyen est ce que si gérald
darmanin est mise en examen il devra
démissionner selon vous il faut poser la
question au premier ministre mais par
rapport à ce qu'il a dit ce qu'il a dit
si la séance
je pense que vous avez la réponse à
cette question mais
il n'en demeure pas moins que nous ne
sommes pas dans cette situation et qu au
contraire précédemment
j'ai banana à été mis hors de cause à
plusieurs reprises donc la mise en
examen c'est un peu une limite qui a été
implicitement posées par le premier
ministre c'est une limite qui est
souvent imposée par le chef de l'état
donc il appartiendra au chef de l'état
et au premier ministre
le cas échéant pour toute affaire
similaire d'un tirer les conséquences
merci beaucoup thani mohamed soilihi
d'avoir répondu à mes questions
et voilà est toujours sur ce même sujet
une dernière réaction celle de muriel
cabaret la nouvelle sénatrice socialiste
de la start qui a tout à l'heure
interrogé le premier ministre
elle est à votre micro alexandre
effectivement mais le cabaret qui était
à l'origine est bien de ce moment fort
de ces questions d'actualité au
gouvernement pour sa première question
d'actualité
muriel cabaret qu'est ce que vous avez
pensé de la réponse très musclé du
premier ministre voilà la réponse du
premier ministre était pleine de colère
parce que je pense qu'on a un fait
mouche dans la question qu'on a imposé
c'était pas seulement la mienne c'était
aussi celle du groupe socialiste bien
évidemment et il était très très mal à
l'aise pour justifier le choix de
monsieur darmana au ministère de
l'intérieur c'est d'ailleurs le problème
qui se pose c'est le fait qu'il était né
mais dans ce ministère et il estime que
vous avez remis aux remises en cause sa
conscience dans cette nomination
vous avez ce sentiment bah je sais pas
mais c'est lui qui utilisé ces mots en
toute conscience j'ai effectivement est
nommé monsieur darmanin ce ministère
mais c'était son problème à lui ce
n'était pas vraiment notre problème à
nous voilà donc c'est en fait une
réaction du premier ministre qui a été
piqué au vif par votre question tout à
fait merci beaucoup
muriel cabaret pour votre première
réaction ici au sénat lors des questions
d'actualité merci beaucoup alexandre
pour toutes ces réactions
autre thématique qui a été largement
abordée et depuis ce matin au sénat la
question des territoires un quart jean
castex se présente comme l'homme des
territoires il a fait une véritable ode
au territoire
ce matin vous l'avais dit dans votre
question tout à l'heure loïc hervé
confiance intelligence proximité
territoire ce sont des mots clés mais ce
ne sont que des mots pour l'instant
alors ce ne sont que des mots vous savez
le discours de politique générale sur
lequel le goût le gouvernement engage sa
responsabilité premier ministre c'est ça
un sens juridique 1
au parlement alors pas au sénat en tout
cas l'assemblée nationale c'est un acte
important un acte de début de mandat
et moi je me réjouir en tant que
sénateur très attaché à la
décentralisation et à la liberté des
territoires que les têtes reviennent
dans grass finalement on nous avait dit
au début du mandat présidentiel
il avait été déjà largement dans le
monde à françois hollande sur un plan
financier et au début du mandat
emmanuel macron on avait entendu qu'il
n'y avait pas une très grande ambition
dames on peut pas on a et va évacuer
l'idée d'un acte iii de la
décentralisation pas de big bang et
c'est alors que du côté des territoires
il y avait une volonté de continuer à
apprendre des compétences et à les
exercer et vous voyez dans le dans le
contexte actuel de crise sanitaire ou de
ou de lutte contre le changement
climatique on se rend bien compte que
c'est sur les territoires que les
politiques publiques sont le mieux mener
et c'est ainsi que une forme de
décentralisation écologique une forme de
décentralisation politique à nouveau ou
de décentralisation des de l'action
économique c'est que ce sont des choses
qui peuvent revenir avec la loi 3d donc
que j'évoquais tout à l'heure dans ma
question dans la réplique à madame gros
pour qu'on ait une capacité à donner au
pays un arsenal législatif qui fasse
confiance au territoire premier ministre
a cité le mot territoire 25 fois dans
son discours de politique générale c'est
considérable alors ce sont des mots oui
il s'agira pour nous par le moteur de
vérifier que ces mots deviennent des
actes car acte de décentralisation
emmanuel macron on avait déjà parlé à la
suite du grand débat elle ne s'est pas
passé grand chose depuis en matière de
décentralisation
qu'est ce qui vous fait croire que là ça
va pouvoir aller plus loin c'est l'air
du temps l'air du temps c'est à dire
l'impression que les français ont eu et
que moi j'ai ressenti très profondément
que dans la gestion d'une crise
sanitaire il fallait de la proximité il
fallait pour s'occuper des français de
leurs problèmes vraiment des des acteurs
de terrain le plus proche possible et
que l'état se limite à un certain nombre
de compétences qu'on appelle
habituellement régaliennes mais qui sont
des compétences stratégiques mais que
l'opérationnel y compris dans quand il
s'agit de
de la santé qui ont il s'agit de de
l'écologique qu'il s'agisse de
l'administration d'un théâtre y compris
sur un plan économique que tout ça se
fasse au plus près du terrain
c'est la subsidiarité et donc du coup je
pense que dans les 600 derniers jours du
mandat le président la république pourra
essayer de tenir cette nouvelle promesse
qu'il a prises effectivement au mou du
grand débat mais que la crise de la
corrida révélé vous gitta il ne reste
que six cents jours c'est peu de temps
certains disent déjà qu'ils ne voient
pas où il y aura la place pour cette
fameuse la 3d dans le calendrier
parlementaire est ce que vous partagez
ces craintes et est ce que vous pensez
aussi que ça va suffire
et bien tout ce discours sur les
territoires pour pouvoir résoudre le
problème démocratique face auxquels on
se trouve aujourd'hui les deux il ya
deux choses d'abord quand on a une
volonté politique de faire passer un
texte on ne fait pas c'est là on à
l'assemblée nationale à mis trois
semaines a examiné le troisième projet
s'est construit magnifique hâtives nous
on va mettre quelques jours dit si d'ici
lundi à hal examiné au sénat
donc quand on a une volonté politique
d'avancer on peut le faire d'ailleurs le
scénario simon lamarre je voulais
absolument le sénat largement anticipée
puisque sous l'égide du président du
sénat gérard larcher des propositions
très concrètes ont été ont été formulées
donc laquelle le premier ministre a un
regard attentif et bien il
il l'a dit et ça aussi où il faut il
faut qu'on puisse qu'on puisse
l'entendre voilà moi je crois qu'il ya
vraiment une
ja il ya une fenêtre elle et elle est
possible il faut l'utiliser à plein et
qu'on fasse cet acte de décentralisation
je pense que nous nos collègues élus
nous le demande chaque jour il vous le
demande chaque jour espérons qu'ils ont
été entendus merci beaucoup loïc hervé
d'avoir participé à ce débrief des
questions d'actualité au gouvernement à
22h vous avez rendez vous avec rebecca
fitoussi et allons plus loin très bonne
soirée sur les chaînes parlementaires
[Musique]